hey what's going on it's Bill Bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast and
I'm just checking
in on
you see how you doing how are
you yeah you're having a tough
day H I had a tough day this morning oh
Jesus
I [__] go out to get a cup of coffee
right cuz what else am I going to do huh
grow as a
person you know am I going to challenge
myself to be a better man am I going to
get out of my comfort zone no going to
go to the same [__] coffee shop get
the same [__] coffee I always get cuz
it makes me feel
safe so I get myself a cup of coffee
right I get my wife her latte made sure
I get her latte cuz you know that's what
you do hey honey what do you what would
you like you know and oh he's thinking
about me and then they [__] lay
off for a couple of
hours Nia's over in the corner so I'm
going to be talking a lot of [__] about
her until she comes over um and what
happens oh [__] Billy
goodart oh Willie trying to do the right
thing I [__] come home and then I
realized oh [__] I was supposed to bring
my car in for service I forgot to do
that so I get the coffees to
go what the [__] are you doing making a
coffee to go it was a [__] joke I
make it to
go I bring it home and then I'm going to
go bring my car over for service right
and I go to the dealership I don't give
a [__] everybody's like you know this
[__] Uber driver just gave me a whole
lecture why why you bring to dealership
they charge you more [__] well you
know what cuz they use the [__] right
parts they got the manual in there and
on on how to torque it down or some
[__] I'm not going to some boot like
just some
[__] satellite
school right I go to Harvard Ro [__]
Rhode Island you know they do that [__]
like those those adjacent schools like
I'm not doing that with the mechanic
because the guy's going to tell me that
he's using genuine Ford [__] Parts
how the [__] do I know I don't know
where to look
you use all Ford parts oh yeah buddy
yeah they're right under the
hood thank you you know I'm not doing
that I'm not going to Jiffy Loop you
know those [__]
people all right those people live in
the sewer that's why that's why they
don't mind being underneath the car all
[__] day right they got them standing
there they they come out at night to
feed and then right at the end before
they go to bed they change the oil and
lube your cars that's what they do
that's how they make their money to buy
a little [__] burlap sack to sleep on
inside the sewer systems of our great
cities here in America and what happens
is is there you know they're they're
nighttime people they're nocturnal so
when they're working on your car half
the time they forget half the time Bill
well I've heard that they forgot then
you drive down the street and your
engine seizes so I go to the [__]
dealership all right I go to get in my
[__] car to go to the goddamn
dealership and I'll you know I'm driving
down the street and I'm feeling this
weird pulling to one side and then this
tire pressure I'm like you got to be
kidding me I got a [__]
flat so I was close enough to my house I
drove back and I'm going around the car
and they don't look flat so I'm like
what the [__] so I get in the car I go
down the road again same thing happens
I'm like Jesus Christ do I need this
have a total [__] meltdown FaceTime
my wife who's in the house who got her
latte who was thinking that she married
the right man so what do I do what do I
do that with the real estate that I gain
I give it right back and throw a [__]
pick six and I call her up and [__]
have a meltdown you know bad enough to
do it just a regular phone call I did it
in FaceTime so I was like I was in the
room it was like I was Haunting her life
I wasn't even there yet I was there
right so I call up triaa and those [__]
right now it's just like we sent you a
virtual text to make it [__] easier
it's not to make it easier it's so you
can make more money give me a [__]
person so of course I I opt out of that
and I wait to get a person on and then I
[__] I I I I get the whole thing
scheduled and I'm like let me [__]
try this one with time I drive down the
street and nothing happens and it's
totally [__] fine so then I have to
call I [__] cancel it they're like
are you sure you want to cancel
it it's like did I come off wishy-washy
when I [__] talked to your computer
the last time yes cancel it and then I
brought it over and and now now it's
it's being uh now they have to look at
the system that for some reason thought
I had a flat tire and I didn't I'll tell
you what [__] annoys me is I know how
to change a goddamn tire and I know how
to change oil it's just that the Jaz ha
that they give you and they have it
bolted down and it's I don't even know
what the [__] it is it's like a a jack
adjacent you know that little tree stand
and then they give you that little
[__]
curved piece of pipe that's supposed to
start up like a [__] car in the
1920s I got to get a real Jack you know
I mean I used to have that one you know
back in the day I have a real Jack and
then I had a piece of pipe to give
myself leverage back when I had my 83
Ford Rain
right so that was basically my morning
and now I'm back and now I'm doing the
podcast hey Nia do you want to come
over uh no no no you I you and I are
interacting on my Instagram from now on
I am what do you mean I am officially
res wait should I make an announcement
hold on you are not officially resigning
I would like well then I'm not taking
pictures of your stupid [__] food
anymore really is that how it's going to
go I like I like this partnership huh I
like you and I like when you come on the
podcast the people like it give the
people what they want hi people so I was
gonna I was going to announce my
official resignation from the podcast
but your man wants it you hear that he
wants
it what are you talk why are you acting
like people don't love you on the
podcast oh you know I've heard some
things oh have you heard some things
well guess what I've heard some things
on something that I have out right now
that I can't promote and I've lit I've
literally heard everything from like you
know this is a borish piece of [__] it's
not even a [__] Movie that that was
the extreme left I just said movie I
guess it might as wellos say that
project project all the way to left and
then the extreme right is going uh oh my
God it's so hard to watch him give into
Hollywood woke [__]
politics but ni I don't give a [__]
about those people I give a [__] about
the people in the middle who just
watched it and said it was funny exactly
that's it the people with taste
oh no cuz some in the middle didn't like
it but I don't give a [__] right it's
like I you know we live in a [__]
world now you're literally politicizing
a stupid
comedy
project comedy project also you you're
Bill Burr you know what I mean you have
a you have a tendency to divide the
masses I think that's great no I don't
you don't think so a little bit no no no
not at all no all they do is report on
the [__] 18 people all the way to the
left or the 18 people all the way to the
right that's also true yeah that's true
you know what you know what it's like
Nia it's like countries talking about
other countries oh boy yeah they do the
same thing all these [__] people are
[__] and all these people are cool
no it's cold in here most people are
cool it's just the extremist [__]
that's that's all you have to get rid of
Nia the extremist [__] the the extremist
goddamn [__] that's what we're going to
call your next special extremist [__]
I'm running for office God I'm going to
drain the swamp of extremist [__] I'm
going to be the first
[Music]
lady NE this is a fantasy you know what
I mean oh what else happens this fantasy
is I don't have to [__] deal with you
giving me [__] tell me to work on my
temper when I'm in the white house I'm
trying to run I'm trying to run a
country here I if you think that if we
were in the white house that I wouldn't
continue to call you to the [__]
carpet for all your [__] and your
antics you think that's going to stop me
well that's what you're supposed to do
never never as as my partner you're
supposed to do that but like that that
that goes both ways it absolutely goes
oh yeah it does doesn't it it does it
does does it does it does all right so
you work on your [__] I'll work on my
[__] is this what you call me on to the
podcast for to be combative with me I
mean yeah that's well you just stuck
yourself in the white house with me that
was my fantasy why wouldn't I be in the
white house too why cuz maybe I want to
be the first single president would
never in a long time would never happen
Billy Playboy coming in there I got a
meeting with uh [__] JLo this week to
talk about uh fat kids in this
country don't you ring my beautiful JLo
into this I don't even know why I picked
her I I don't know why either I mean
she's gorgeous she's saying at the last
inauguration maybe that's why you
thought of her she sang at the in
inauguration she
did yep and that's all I'm gonna say on
this why would you do that I don't
understand I don't understand my husband
so I'm very I'm very pro pro JLo that's
right Pro JLo I get it and pro you know
what your ESPN is it's like celebrity
websites ESPN well like I you know I sit
there and I like I watch like sports and
I get into this stupid [__] oh this is
one of your like like super over
simplistic analogies by the way oh I'm
sorry I didn't realize following
celebrities was so [__] deep no
you're not deep because you're the one
that's always going like you know it's
kind of like when you watch the real
houseway and it's like Bill I know what
you're talking about like you don't have
to make like some sort of analogy like
you like this the way I like sports it's
like yeah that's not even what I was
saying okay cuz I was going to be like
why the [__] are you following these
celebrities lives in relationship and
then I was me like oh this is just kind
of like why am I why do I give a [__]
about the Patriots not doing well this
year stupid why do you yeah why do you
wear a man's name on the back of a
jersey you know I I don't do that you
don't wear jerseys I don't wear I'm not
dating
him I feel like I've seen you wear a
hockey jersey like years ago or like in
an old photo of you or like when you
were a kid you know or like a teenager
or your 20s but you definitely no you
don't wear any I wore a jersey if I was
playing pickup hockey right okay oh
that's what it is that's what it is when
you used to play hockey yeah and I used
to go out and I would wear my J Miller
Bruins Jersey which was hilarious
because I couldn't skate and I wasn't
tough so it actually brought shame to
that great man's
name um anyway you look cute thank you
so do you we had fun last night we went
trick-or-treating it was the first time
first time my son went trick-or-treating
it's so funny oh my God the first time
you bring a kid out they're always super
shy for like two houses and then they
figured out like wait a minute I just go
up there and say happy Halloween and
they give me candy I feel like none of
them say Trick or Treat I I heard a few
kids saying happy Halloween which of
course is totally fine but I don't feel
like people say Trick or Treat anymore
you know what I love I just love like
like this generation and La names for
kids you know I was joking about that
it's like Brook
Brooklyn Brooklyn you have to wait for
stanza stanza oh hi
Soliloquy it's like those are not names
are you a princess oh my gosh she's so
cute but the kid kids and then there's
always those [__] kids that are just
way too old to be trick-or-treating
there was like kids these teenage kids
they were taller than I was their voices
had dropping they like d a Dr coming up
there remember like at our old place I
was incensed because these teenage like
they weren't even wearing costumes maybe
one girl was wearing caters and they
just showed up at the door they don't
say happy Halloween they don't say
trick- or- treat they're just like
expecting candy and then they have this
[__] grit on their face like we
don't know what they're doing yeah it's
like I also you'd have enough money in
your pocket to go to the [__] grocery
store and get some candy get the [__]
out of here like these are for the kids
the only the but you never said that No
I gave it because what am I going to do
I like kind of like got freaked out I'm
like okay are they going to like egg the
house or do something crazy I'm like
here take the [__] the Milky Way
kidss don't egg houses anymore they go
on Instagram and make up stories about
you oh okay even worse I was like no
take the Milky Ways nobody wants these
anyway they would film your house and be
like okay just to give you the heads up
I went there I was nice I said trick or
treat like there like a reporter like at
a you know live
from like Channel 7 News yeah giving you
the [__] and I'm I'm here Brooklyn
Soliloquy live out in front of this
house that didn't give me full siy
stanza don't forget stanza stanza stanza
is in there too right I didn't hear I
did hear Brooklyn you did yeah that's
Brooklyn's a cool name yeah I love I
love that name that's a great name okay
well we we've established sza and
soloqui those are like those are like
music are you in like your music head
right now that you said stands and
Soliloquy I actually thought that that
had to do with
writing oh a soliloquy it does I don't
know oh God all right guys this is that
that little back and forth should have
inspired all of
you that we actually have jobs and get
paid to do things well that was that was
that was even too dumb for me and I was
involved um anyway uh what did I want to
talk about here yeah so last night yeah
my son was like really like shy I almost
had to like carry him up to walk in the
first one and then by like the third
house he would do this he' go happy
Halloween he would like yell it down the
thing and he was dressed like Luigi he
was so freaking cute and I found out
that he he's all about he likes the
lollipops like he he be he was totally
into that and then also I would be going
like buddy just take one just take one
and he his like Luigi gloves that didn't
fit you know what I mean they're like
three sizes too big and he would just go
in and just just like just grab you know
what I realize we're going to have to
before they get home we're going to have
to hide that candy cuz he's going to go
in she she knows how to regulate but
he'll be like all over and he'll start
crying it'll be a whole thing oh so in
other words she's wired like you and
he's wired like me yeah there you go I
mean all right well keep him away from
the
bourbon and more weights than one yes
for sure fa show all right well listen
to speaking of faux show oh um I have a
bunch of dates coming up this uh this
Saturday night myself in club soda Kenny
this Saturday night s
in the park
satday in the park think it was the 4th
of
July people walking people talking a man
selling ice
cream something something that song
Chicago man formerly Chicago Transit
Authority and uh name themselves after
the the subway that was like a thing
Manhattan Transfer it was just like oh
my God my dad used to listen to them I
love the Manhattan Transfer they're so
corny but so good those harmonies what
was it do the
hustle they the ones who sang that no
they sang I don't know what they sang
does Andrew put music at the end of the
Thursday one yes Andrew can you find
some Manhattan Transfer to play at the
end of this to transfer from this
episode to an older one I like that um
this Saturday night um going to be at
the bought to TD Bank North Boston
Garden home of your 80 And1 Boston
Bruins one in OT the other night
sniper
um uh doing the comics come home I think
the
37th Comics come home come home you guys
don't be like that come home it's going
to be okay we can talk about this we can
work it out you've been away long enough
come home come home um
that's going to be uh who else is going
to be on the card that night oh God
Rachel
Feinstein Mark Maron who else I've only
posted it 9 million times Bobby Kelly
Bobby
Bobby um is Rachel from
Boston no I think she's from New York
okay I don't know I just I met her
coming home she's she's not coming home
she's leaving home she's leaving home
well initially it was mainly Boston
comedians they come home all right and
now it's just anybody right anybody come
on over come on over yeah it sounds jok
it sounds good it does it does it sounds
very inviting uh then I'm at Foxwoods
the next night two shows I haven't been
to Foxwoods in ages that was always a
fun time you used to go to Foxwoods I
went to Foxwoods with my mother my
mother to see Joe the R&B singer and my
mom had is that the guy if you're
cheating on me I don't want to know that
guy uh he's the one saying I want to
know I want I know what turns you
on so my mom had two margaritas and was
women love that song complete disaster
and it was so funny it was so much fun
oh your mom got trashed she did I mean
it doesn't take much she's like you know
a really lightweight but we went with my
my aunt who passed away sadly um a
couple years ago and it was it was
probably one of my favorite memories of
all of us together so I haven't been to
Foxwoods probably since then and that
was ages she got you mother hammered I
got her hammered on
Margaritas we hit the slots the slots
after that the only time I ever went to
Foxwoods when I wasn't working is I went
with a degenerate Gambler comedian you
just that you've talked about this
before right like you can't just say
Gambler you have to say a degenerate
gambl degenerate cuz he didn't go there
to gamble this guy was a degenerate yeah
he went there to what stay up the whole
freaking night playing cards and like I
was opening for him so I went with him
and we stayed up until 4:5 in the
fraking morning and I was just sitting
there I remember him just laughing at me
nodding off as I was as I was as he was
driving home and you were just trying to
hang I thought I needed to do that I was
like well this guy's headlining I got to
do I should have been like dude I'm not
[__] doing that yeah I was going to
say there's no way in hell you would
ever do that today no well you're like a
do the show and go home guy that's
that's it yeah but back then I was uh I
was I was a people pleaser oh yeah you
were hanging you were hanging out I was
hanging let me sck a little closer to
you I was out in these streets Nia just
pleasing everybody but except for myself
um where did you get one of those little
microphones to put on your phone I went
to the microphone store I like it it's
called Uh Mikey's mics right down the
street Mikey Michaelson's mics that's
right Mikey Michaelson if you need a
microphone if your voice isn't loud
enough I can amplify it come on down to
Mikey's mics I mean your voice is
definitely loud enough all right how did
that feel felt good it felt good shut up
you love me and I've been a sweetheart
to you you're all right come on I you
you're the best that's right that's
right there you go see I got to squeeze
the compliment out but eventually it
comes okay so after that I have a day
off then I go to Northfork Virginia mhm
they're coming off a big victory over
the Miami Hurricanes I don't need to
tell you that Nia who is um University
of Virginia oh I was going to say they
have a sports like a professional sports
team this is college yes College okay
look at you knowing that they don't have
I mean I think I would think that they
would probably DC fans I mean I know a
few things I mean I know a few things I
know like the dtas don't have any
[__] sports team right professional
yeah no they don't but they crush it in
hockey they do they crush it yeah they
they do they do and they went like the
ncah it's always like them Maine there's
somebody else that's all bu gets in
there too
um yeah I don't know all right so then
after that I go to Atlanta Nia's old
stomping grounds and then I go to
Hollywood Florida cuz I'm a big phony
right even when I go to Florida I'm
still Hollywood you know what I mean do
I go to Daytona where all the real
[__] people
are last time I went to Daytona I went
to the 500 with Nate Barat shout out to
him crushing it on
SNL oh great yeah killed it on SNL mhm I
always like uh love seeing Comics that
I'm huge fans of being on the show and
my favorite thing is like in the end
saying good night is like I can't even
tell you what like a relief that is it's
just so much freaking pressure and you
just so like oh my God I did it and they
start playing that song and that clap
clap clap clap as you're coming up
you're like holy [__] oh yeah were
they're playing the piano yeah oh my God
it's just and the saxophone comes in
yeah and you're like oh my it was fun I
did it need to go you need to go viral
again for another you know hot monologue
oh what's he gonna say this time that
Billy Burr he's so
unpredictable he's mean he says it like
it is he's married I don't like that
anymore go [__] cry in your bowl of
soup by yourself you [__] losers
sorry all right yeah I know by the way
all of these yeah these I don't know n
you got to stop reading comments I know
it's never going to be good it's never
it's you just got to do whatever the
overall is if overall it's positive it's
fine I'm working on I know and it is
these people that say negative [__] it
has nothing to do with you it has to do
with the fact that their life isn't
going the way they wanted it's sad I'm
going to get better at it it's sad you
know I know the negative ones they it it
takes a lot to get me going because I
always look at like well you know I'm a
bald Ginger I can see why I'd come at me
too no you know what I mean don't do
that though don't don't make it like
okay for the bullies to bully you
they're not bullies near they're [__]
right well that's definitely true but
I'm saying like for you to you know I am
a bald Ginger it's like what does that
have to do with if you're talking [__]
and involves
typing let's not act like we're going to
a weigh-in and you're getting in
somebody's Grill you're sitting there
with a little keyboard you know what
else you right you know they're just
using their little thumm thumbs their
little thumm thumbs on their on their
phone oh yeah they got little they have
little boxing gloves on them too when
they said Mean
Tweets um just so you know that they're
telling it like it is um so Nia there's
an election coming up next year I can't
tell you how [__] upset I am by that
why cuz I oh my God the [__] dragging
it out the dumpster fire that we'll have
to deal with in the new cycle oh Jesus
can you imagine Joe Biden in a debate
how's he even going to do
it I hope he pulls it
together I'm I I just I'm just hope I
want somebody in their 40s that can like
make a speech because because the bottom
line is they're still going to work for
the same people they're still going to
be selling Wars you know they're still
going to back the banks and the Ponzi
scheme it doesn't really [__] matter
but it would be nice to have a good
Hostess you
know welcome to
Applebees I'll be speaking for you for
the next four years someone that's still
a light in their eye sure sure I mean
the last two people NE I mean it's just
like it's like a talent contest you know
it's like karaoke I feel like the last
two presidents have been like like
presidential karaoke would you ever do
karaoke and if you did what song would
you sing uh I would do karaoke and I
would sing let me put my love Into You
Babe by ACDC I knew it was going to be
an ACDC song is that a real name of it
let me put my love it's a great driving
song and if you don't listen to the
lyrics
you don't notice that it's a little uh
little aggressive let me put my love
into you I think so well that's all
right he just wants to [__] you I mean
there's nothing wrong with saying you
want to put your love into somebody I
don't ever say that to me hey Nia guess
what I want to do later on today please
don't I don't want you I don't want
it please keep it why are you afraid of
love oh God see that you have intimacy
issues and you're
puty hey sweetheart let me put my love
into you babe you know what I'm actually
really hungry let put my love on the
line Are we almost done with this
podcast well I'm sorry are we keeping
you for your busy day just I want to
order some
food I want to hang out with you is what
I want to do but I could [__] work to
do well you had that yeah you had that
opportunity to do so and I told you what
you needed to do to do that and you
didn't want to do it so yeah cuz I have
work to do cuz you married a [__]
beast oh boy here we go here it is I
can't talk a little [__] yeah you can
talk I had a good had a good couple of
weeks all right definitely earn it no
promo on any sort of project hey and yet
listen guess who knew about it guess who
knew about that project who OH
ZIP recruiter yeah you know it takes a
team of people to make this show
successful does it I was going to say
what team it's just me and Andrew your
underwear it's generic copy Just Go With
It okay uh just like it takes a solid
team to to make any business successful
um so if you're hiring how do you find
the best people for your team zip
recruiter and right now you can try old
zip recruit it do uh for free I I read
that wrong and right now you can try it
for free and
zip I'm starting it
up grp.com
bur the next one is going to be the
devil Read where it goes backwards like
the old school like white heavy metal
did you miss that whole thing you missed
that whole part of Music didn't you
that's not uh here's why you'll be
grateful when you
try if you play that for if you if you
you play that forward it says zip
recruiter for your hiring matching
technology zip uses smart technology to
scan thousands of resumés to find the
most qualified people for your job well
Nia they say the name of their company
50 [__] times in this great match
notification for zip recruiter
um I used to work with a guy like that
who over enunciated all the time he's
like hello my name is
Brian uh ZIP recruiter lets you this is
why we would read this ZIP recruiter
lets the most qualified people for your
job know they are at a great match for
it and encourages them to apply uh
invite to apply you can use this
Z recruiter feature to easily send a
personal invite to apply to top
candidates so they're more likely to
apply all right uh see why so many
business owners and hiring managers are
thankful for zip recruiter four to five
employees who post on zip recruiter can
get a quality candidate within the first
day I'd be super grateful if you could
go to this exclusive website right now
to try zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com bur again that
zip that was a sneeze
read.com bur spell out Burr crazy Ur r r
zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire don't
you like that that's old school
salesmanship I love that that was a
great read puts a smile on my face oh a
lot of twists and turns and ups and
downs and here's the one that's been
here forever everybody it's stamps.com
a they've been here they've been R
rocking with you from the beginning
that's right from the beginning all the
way back all the way back to like uh I
would say like uh maybe 2011 is
stamps.com
hey Nia did you forget to add stamps.com
to your holiday wish list last year damn
it I'm telling you wait we all make
mistakes that's in the I do about it
well stamps.com has been helping
businesses like yours you have a
business Like Yours save time and money
in
line not possible and money during the
holiday rush for 25 years with easy
access to USPS and UPS services in
premium rates for all your postage needs
the holidays are hard enough Nia uh make
sure make things easier than ever with
stamps.com if you need a package pickup
you can easily schedule it through your
stamps.com dashboard and if you sell
products online stamps.com
seamlessly no panty lines here Nia
seamlessly connects with every major
market place and shopping cart premium
discounts and supplies at your
fingertips running low order shipping
and mailing supplies labels and even
printers from the supply store get huge
career carrier discounts up to 84% off
USPS and UPS rates to help your bottom
line plus stamps.com automatically tells
your cheapest tells you your cheapest
and fastest shipping options get access
to USPS and UPS Services right to your
we already did this sign up with the
promo code Burr for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale no long-term
contracts
commitments um commitments or contracts
sorry just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and enter code bur bu RR and that is it
everybody that is the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast I hope you're watching the World
Series or the world serious as Bugs
Bunny used to say all three games have
been fantastic there's a lot of drama
you know the Rangers came back and that
guy that hit the walk-off home run I'm
not good with the names he ended up I
don't know if it was an oblique I don't
know if he messed up his back but
everybody's wondering what's going on
they got Captain America playing
shortstop I'm rooting for the Rangers
simply because they've never won before
but if the Diamondbacks win it's an
amazing run because they were a wildcard
team and they knocked off the Braves and
it's reminding me Nia of when the New
York Giants with Eli knocked off my
undefeated Patriots they were they they
were on the road as a wild card team one
of the great runs of all time and as
much as it crushed my soul when they
lost it was an amazing thing to watch in
sports and Nia that's one to grow on
this has been the Thursday and enjoy the
music enjoy a little Manhattan Transfer
you know what I always forget to do I
always forget to put it on airplane mode
and right at the end somebody ends up
calling me um enjoy Manhattan transfer
all right Nia's request and uh edit it
into this wonderful podcast I like to
think it's wonderful by the great Andrew
Themis and then we have a bonus episode
of the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast coming up
after this uh a lot of crazy stuff going
on in the world doesn't mean you can't
be a nice person all right just to give
you something to think about all right
thank you
bye-bye you
on I'm a
[Music]
Ral hey what's going on it's Bill bur
and it's time for the Monday Morning
podcast from Monday Monday November
2nd 2015 oh my my God it's
November you know the greatest holiday
of the year for
me is what Thanksgiving I like it it's
family you get to eat what about Flag
Day that's a good one isn't it why don't
you go underground support that Indie
band right he could do that Labor Day is
another good
one uh blueberry pancake day or whatever
the [__] it was that time when I was in
Atlanta I tell you guys that story I
went in to do morning TV the worst
[__] thing a comedian can ever do it
doesn't sell one [__] ticket you know
watches morning TV [__] uh
stay-at-home
moms you know you know those and in the
in the those awful stay-at-home moms a
cool stay-at-home mom probably Pops in a
good movie or some [__] like that but
those you know those ones that talk to
kids like they're [__]
morons and they do it like you know it's
bad enough when the kids really little
but when they're like 6 years old and
they're still going like oh how was your
day today they do that [__] up and
down
talking with like their eyes really
[__] open eyebrows way
up you just want to [__] slap him in
the back of the head like what are you
doing and do me a favor don't talk to my
dog like that cuz you're going to freak
her out and she's going to go for your
throat all she's going to hear is
heightened excitement and she's going to
be thinking someone's going to beat the
[__] out of her again like whoever what
whoever the [__] did it to her before I
got her isn't that right
Cleo huh she's over there already
sleeping this [__] dog slept for
eight goddamn hours last night right
right next to me by the way I I had seen
her in like two weeks so I was watching
the KC Met game and I actually fell
asleep before the end of it I was so
[__] tired and then of course I wake
up afterwards and I see KC celebrating
by the way congratulations to Kansas
City my condolence to Mets fans uh just
two [__] great teams and it was so
great to see you know not to see Yankees
Red Sox Cardinals Giants the [__]
people who were have been in it it's
nice to see new blood um so anyways I'm
sitting there I'm trying to
[__] see the highlight and I'm just
sitting there and my dog like this my
dog is a master like cuddler the thing
is all away like legs tucked underneath
and it's [__] got it its head right
on my chest chest right with its muzzle
almost like just like staring at me and
it's snoring so I don't want to waake
the thing up and I'm sitting there and
the remotes on the other side of my
[__] dog and I'm like I can't wait
this thing up and I'm sitting there
waiting for a [__] highlight and they
got this
guy who's just standing there going on
and on and on and on and on and on and
on about the [__]
game about what happened and blah blah
blah it's like show a [__] highlight
you jerk off what are you the
president you giv some [__] State of
the Union thing so many [__] ESPN
shows now are just two [__] people
sitting there standing there walking
around talking talking talking that
[__] Channel I want to see
highlights show them all [__] day
long I will sit I used to watch sports
center back when I had the time I'd
watch it like three times in a [__]
row I didn't give a [__] same jokes same
[__] Clips all of that I loved it
these [__] idiots sitting there
talking and talking and talking I would
I should talk right I do a [__]
podcast by myself um so then I turn the
[__] Channel I'm like all right they
got like 52 ESPN I go up to ESPN too
there's two other jerk offs sitting
there talking talking talking talking
talking and they're showing the scores
and all of this type of [__] and for the
life of me I haven't seen it I heard
what
happened I heard they let that they let
the pitcher stay in and then he walked
the [__] guy then there was a double
blah blah blah blah blah and then there
was a play at third and the [__] guy you
know they looked at each other and then
right throws the ball and the guy
[__] takes off it's a close play at
the plate the throw is little I've yet
to see
it I just want to see a
highlight um so anyway so I don't really
know uh I don't know what happened all
of that that I know is cuz actually not
CU of ESPN it's because I talked to Paul
verie this morning um who by the
way is really excited that the Mets lost
I found during this series that he
[__] he hates the Mets he hates the
Mets fans don't let him say anything
differently don't let him try to be a
Class Act I'm telling you the the the
running joke on the tour was uh Paul
verie wants no joy in
Queens cuz we were all sitting there
like I'm a [__] you know Red Sox fan
I shouldn't like any team from New York
but I don't give a [__] right it's the
Mets you know they haven't won it since
' 86 [__] it I don't care if they win it
um so I want I wanted to see I basically
I wanted see a seven game series is what
I wanted to see and uh but verie was
very silently rooting very hard against
the
Mets and he wouldn't admit it and he
just no no no no I I don't I don't care
you know I I just want I just want to
see a good series and then he he get he
would get just a little too excited when
Casey would be coming back so um anyways
I'm just sitting here [__] babbling
uh I did miss Halloween this year um
it's the first time I have not been at
my house during Halloween um which I'm
actually happy about cuz I told you
where I live I live in this weird area
where it's like if you go a little if
you go to the right it gets really nice
if you go to the left there's like a
check cashing place like a block away
you know what I mean and I'm sort of in
the middle so during Halloween I get
everything from Little snot-nose Rich
Kids to like what I had like a year ago
with this [__] like I don't know 37y
old dude showed he looked like a [__]
homeless Jim cochi he just [__]
showed up right big [__] mustache Tom
celic style and he was just standing
there and I just opened the
door oh I know no he had some kids with
him and they all left in he had a bag
too and he held the bag out and I just
went really and he just goes yes I go
really or something like that seriously
he just goes yes and I just [__] gave
what was I going to do I was joking in
Chicago it's like I got to give it to
him he knows where the [__] I live right
that's the thing you can't [__] people
over on Halloween they know where you
live they they're going to do something
they're going to walk down your [__]
thing they're going to [__] punch
your mailbox and pull the little flag
off of it you know yank some [__] I
don't know plant out of the
ground which I don't give a [__] right
if it's not [__] making me any food
what do I need it for well because they
exhale oxygen shut
up we get
it so
anyways um dude I I completely shot from
that tour I am so [__]
exhausted um and it isn't from the shows
the shows were great the people were
great the venues were great but
um I [__] drank every single night
for [__] two
weeks and
um every night I was like yeah I can't
do it I can't do it and that was the
joke the joke started to become before
every
show we would just be going like all
right man tonight we're just going home
going home early we're just [__] get
an eight hours workout right maybe find
a spa we'll take a steam have a nice
[__] healthy breakfast everybody's
nodding yeah yeah yeah and then [__]
uh somebody finishes their set and they
just got the devil in their eye when
they come off and then they would look
at me and I would just start laughing
and the next thing you know we go out
again so we're in Chicago mom My Kind of
Town Chicago
is a bunch of mustaches Chicago is
actually I didn't see a lot of
them Michigan Avenue with all those
shops 20 hairy Cary
restaurants which ones the original um
so
anyways we ended up going out one
night um
I I'm trying to I'm trying to piece this
together this is the drunkest I've been
in like [__] 10 years we went out to
this this this bar called the Liars club
and it was like a bar that basically a
bunch of bands hung out at and we
[__] get in there and I don't plan on
doing any [__] damage whatsoever
right friend of mine lives in town she's
a photographer she came down to take
some pictures right she brings her crew
of people we go out and just [__] get
into the
bar and I don't know I don't know what
happened they [__] go what kind of
music do you like and I said well I like
and bartnik SE how about ACDC right and
they just played like all this [__] you
never [__]
hear all the [__] you never hear
everybody always plays You Shook Me All
Night although somebody did Play You
Shook Me All Night Long uh they played
like kicked in the
teeth down payment
blues um hous is on fire they playing
[__] off powerage flick of the
switch you know side two a Highway to
Hell dude and me and bartnik were going
[__]
nuts like verie was an angel that night
he barely drank he just said he wanted
to go home he was just sitting there and
like at one point bartnik you know who's
like the size of like [__] Cam Neely
right he's [__] doing the Angus you
know Chuck Berry thing going across the
bar people are going [__] nuts and
everybody just kept buying shots and
like an [__] I just kept doing them I
think I threw down like nine or 10 shots
while I was drinking whiskey so I was
like chasing whiskey shots with whiskey
and
um you know you wouldn't think that you
could go out on a dance floor and dance
to uh ACDC but God damn it I did
it oh and did I pay for
it I [__] paid for it and then I I
you know by the end of the night I I
vaguely remember leaving the
bar it might have been the best night of
the [__] tour we had so much [__]
fun verie actually said like he was
sitting there cuz he wasn't even
drinking he was going like I actually
was enjoying you and bartnik putting on
a clinic on how to have fun in a bar he
was like dude you guys were going I
don't even remember this he goes you
guys were like headbanging he's like bro
you're air drumming on the bar and then
next thing you know me and arck are both
out on the dance floor dancing to
ACDC with this stupid disco ball going
around us it was like if it was a movie
it would have been like uh verie was
saying it would have been like the
Montage scene of when me and Joe becomes
best friends before like we [__]
uh before something whatever happens
sends it in you know what you remember
the Naked
Gun you remember the Naked Gun when uh
lesie neelon and Priscilla Presley are
doing all the [__] running down the
beach coming out of platoon laughing
their asses off it was basically that it
was that that's what we did and the next
day like I [__] woke up you know
still in my clothes in my
bed and like I had all these plans I'm
in Chicago I'm in one of the greatest
cities in the country and I had all
these plans of what I was going to do
and I swear to God like I couldn't get
out of bed I couldn't get out of bed
till like [__] 3: in the afternoon I
was like what I'm a [__] idiot and
then at 5:00 I went
down I went downstairs and uh I tried to
get something to eat and I was no wait
ver came up to my
room ver came up to my room and we were
just sitting there [__] watching TV
and he was just laughing at how
[__] just beat up I was you know and
of course he felt great cuz he was a
[__] angel that night and I um we
ended up watching something on TV one of
the sick sick stories ever and we're
like dude this has to be a [__]
movie and uh of course in the end they
they they said that they were going to
turn into a movie it was basically about
this guy right it was this [__] show
about serial killers so of course we're
going to watch
it right and I'm sitting there eating a
[__] Burger you know just trying to
you know grease always [__] offsets
the [__] alcohol it's awful I'm out
of shape again guys is what I'm trying
to say um so we're watching this thing
about [__] serial killers
and the whole time they're talking about
this this drug dealer kid we're like how
the [__] does this and they keep showing
this serial killer guy it's like does
and they're showing the drug dealer
older you know and not in jail and all
that [__] going what the [__]
happened you know just the way they put
it together it was riveting you're like
what the [__] is going on here so
basically what happened was there was
this kid right he played football they
called him the Assassin because every
game game he ever played he took
somebody out right was it the Assassin
was that Jack Tatum Jack
Tatum now I forget what it was something
like
Assassin
so he [__] uh and just movie star
good looks all right and he's the star
of the football team and the lady's
sitting there interviewing him going as
he's walking around his high school
going like so you were uh you were
basically a legend here and he goes yeah
I was
he wasn't being arrogant he said yeah he
goes they retired my jersey they had
like pictures of me up on the wall and
all that blah blah blah blah all the
women loved him I mean this guy was just
like it
was he looked like a movie star in his
life was a movie so his big Achilles
heel was he he didn't have money and he
wanted to keep up with the rich kids so
he started dealing drugs and he ended up
being really good at it and by the time
he was like 20 years old this [__]
guy was making making like a million
dollars a year crushing it right he's
got a fake you know wall in his walk-in
closet where he's got another room where
he's keeping all the money in a safe
he's throwing all these [__] crazy
parties and it almost seemed like this
American Greed type story as opposed to
this serial killer thing they keep going
back to this serial killer [__] piece
of [__] who's killing these girls these
teenage
girls so long story short he's laying in
bed one night and he's just thinking I
got to get out of this life I'm so sick
of looking over my shoulder I can't do
this anymore how am I going to get out
of this but he's addicted to the money
he's addicted to the life and all of
that type of stuff and he he just
rattling on the door and I'm thinking oh
[__] it's the serial killer and he
obviously fought the guy in one what the
[__] happens right all of a sudden the
door [__] blasts open and all these
[__] was it is it the ATF that shows
up when you get busted as a drug
dealer was that Alcohol Tobacco farmer I
don't know what the [__] it is so
anyways they [__] come FDA Food Drug
Administration the uh Transit Chicago
Transit Authority I don't know what the
[__] it is whatever the [__] that thing
is they come [__] blasting through
the
door run up you know a bunch of guys
with the [__] minor helmets on with
the [__] ues from a Steven Seagal
movie going get on the ground if you
[__] look at me I'll blow your
[__] head off and the whole thing was
over and he disgraced his family name
and they never said it but I imagine
probably took his [__] pictures down
off of the high school and all of that
type of [__] you know did some OJ [__]
right take all his trophies and all that
[__] [__] so it's over right so then
he's sitting in
jail
um and they tried to get him to flip and
this is K just some [__] kid from the
suburbs right so I'm thinking well he's
out he must have ratted somebody out so
he doesn't rat anybody out he's like I'm
not telling on anybody so then they're
like all right well [__] you so now
we're you're not going to help us out
we're going to [__] give you you know
the full extent of the law we're going
to uh prosecute you so they gave him 10
years the guy gets 10 years he's in like
a minimum security cuz you know he
didn't really uh have any violent past
or anything he was just getting people
addicted to drugs that's all he was
doing so his dad is
devastated and all that [__] and he he
goes to jail and uh meanwhile the serial
killer guys out there killing these
girls
so I'm thinking what the [__] and they
keep going to commercial me and ver
looking at each other going how the [__]
are they going to tie this [__] thing
together so long story short
um they ended up catching the serial
killer guy uh I forget how he [__] up
but they ended up catching him and one
of those things where you seem like
relieved and all of that type of [__]
and uh but he had this thing where he
wouldn't admit to all of them and if he
came at him he would just clam up and
wouldn't say [__] so he ends up going to
jail for like like either one or two
murders for Life he's never [__]
getting out so meanwhile there's all
these parents whose daughters were
killed by this guy and they don't know
where they are and all they just want is
the body they want [__] closure and
these parents are just tortured by this
[__] thing all right so they're
trying to figure out because he won't
talk to them he won't tell them anything
and he's also in denial and he keeps
going like actually I didn't kill him
and blah blah blah blah blah and then
one day be like oh I did and I blacked
out I don't remember like the guy was
just a [__] creepy goddamn mess right
so they end up coming up with this idea
that they need a charismatic person to
talk to this to befriend this serial
killer gain the guy's trust and maybe
he'll tell them where like the bodies
are and that type of [__] so they go to
this [__] dude Captain
America you know the football player the
movie star looking guy who [__] his
whole life up cuz he got involved in
drugs right and they approach him to go
from his minimum security to go into a
Maximum Security Prison with his
murderers rapist animals [__] maniacs
right and um you know to go in there and
they said if you if you get this
information out we'll take your sentence
and we'll just wipe out the rest of it
we'll set you free he'd already done
like three four
years so meanwhile Captain America's dad
had a series of Strokes you know and was
basically going to die and he had to go
see him I mean it's like a [__] movie
so he goes all right [__] it I'll I'll
do it but I want an in writing that
you're definitely going to let me go so
they say yeah so they go all right he
goes here they go here's the deal we
don't want you to approach him for at
least 6
months cuz he's very cagy and if you
[__] you know come at the guy the
wrong way he just [__] walls himself
off and that's it all right so this kid
comes he goes in he goes fine cool and
he walks in there he's like I don't have
6 months my dad's going to die within
the first two months two I'm sorry first
two hours he goes into the [__]
jail and he [__] uh on purpose
accidentally bumps into the
guy and then he immediately apologizes
he goes I'm sorry about that buddy I
didn't see you stand there hey he goes
I'm new here do you know where the
library is and the guy tells him where
the library is and he goes thanks man uh
you know and he said something the
effect of uh yeah you're a good guy
gives him a little slap on the shoulder
that's it and goes to the [__]
library and they set it up where his
[__] his cell was right across the
hall from the other guy and he says to
him he goes hey man he he runs into him
again hey where you staying blah blah he
goes oh that's crazy man you want him
right across he oh it's good to be with
a good guy like you blah blah blah right
across from each other
and he goes uh so then [__] the
serial killer guy one day goes hey you
want to get lunch with me and my friends
and at this point me and verie were
[__] laughing our balls off going
like this kind of social [__] happens in
prison like okay uh some friends of mine
uh going some other uh murderers and
serial killers we're going to get some
uh maybe get some uh you know frapping
uh [__] rap or something you want to
come down just kind of hang out I'll
meet you down in the commissary right
you always think it's all just getting
shanked and trying not to get raped
right so he goes yeah cool so long story
he gains this guy's [__] confidence
and one time he actually goes in and he
sees the guy he's got a map with all
these red dots on it and all that [__]
he's trying to get to it blah blah blah
so the Guy starts opening up and he
finally ends up telling them the [__]
stories um of all the women that he
killed and all of that [__] and uh and
sort of kind of mentioned he gave him
like sort of enough information about
where the bodies
were and the Captain America guy kind of
[__] up cuz once he got the
information he thought he had enough
information to find all the bodies and
get himself out of prison and he just
couldn't oh wait I forgot the best part
I'm sorry this going to be like a
Tarantino movie now we're going to jump
backwards another way he gained the
guy's confidence was one day they was
sitting in the TV room watching
TV he's sitting next to this guy and
this big [__] giant dude just gets up
and turns the
channel without talking to anybody and
as he turns the channel the serial
killer who was like a Meek little guy
and he just kind of went he just sort of
said out loud to nobody he was like Hey
I I was watching that like powerlessly
really [__] weird psycho thing and
the [__] Captain America dude walked
up to the big dude and knocked him out
just beat the guy's ass hit him with an
uppercut [__] forearm shiver and just
sent this guy flying through some chairs
and then they stuck him in the hole
that's what happened and then when he
[__] comes out tell me this doesn't
sound like a [__] I almost don't even
believe it so that's when he gained the
guy's confidence that's when the dude
told him and the second he tells him
this dude Captain America couldn't hold
it in anymore and he goes dude you know
what you're a sick [__] piece of [__]
blah blah blah and flipped out on him
and then the guy the syill just backed
up and he goes he goes who sent you he
goes so and so sent you right and he
named the prosecutor and then he just
[__] disappeared and the map
disappeared too so then it's like they
didn't get the
map so there was a thing we don't know
where the [__] bodies still are blah
blah blah blah blah but you got them to
admit to these [__] murders so we
know that the women are at least dead BL
blah basically in the end he did enough
where he got out
um and the whole time we were watching
this [__] thing we were just going
like this is a this is a [__] movie
now I guarantee you when they do the
[__] movie they don't even need to
add any mustard to it but I guarantee
you in the movie he won't flip out in
the end you know or if he flips out but
then he somehow and then that'll be the
last little like hicup like oh no they
didn't find the map in the movie he'll
find the map and then the parents will
actually get closure but in real life
you
know it's not a [__] movie that sucks
but isn't that unbelievable that that's
like a it's so [__] nuts like at one
point they were visiting his old house
and he showed he goes yeah I used to
live here I used to live here I had all
these cars I threw like a [__] 20
keger here one night and he goes up into
the room and he shows the secret place
where his safe is
um and you know those Fort KNX [__]
things it's just I don't know man it was
[__] uh an incredible story whatever
whatever I know half of I'm [__]
glorifying a goddamn drug dealer right
isn't that what I'm doing um and in the
end I know you guys wanted a happy
ending there wasn't a happy ending cuz
he [__] he kind of screwed it up in
the end but they still let him go though
just sort of odd
right you know this is weird and
uncomfortable to watch at this point you
know all these videos they show where
there's cops beating up uh black dudes
and all that type of stuff you know
what's really weird is to watch white
kids [__] with cops
like I saw one kid was doing this thing
where he was drinking a beer where you
weren't supposed to drink a beer he did
like a magic trick and the cop goes you
can't drink here and he keeps [__]
drink keeps drinking then he ends up
putting it in the bag and then the the
[__] bottle disappears he was like a
magician and it's just like you know
that made me miss the Chappelle show cuz
he would have done a sketch about that
and then would have showed the black guy
trying to do the same thing where he
would get like a third into the trick in
the [__] bottle would be smashed over
his
head
um I don't know and I usually don't go
for that whole
[__] you know if this person does
this but if that person does that I mean
after just seeing some of those videos
and I'm not saying all cops are
bed you know it's like
comedians you know that we're not all
hacks we don't all have lampshades on
our heads we're not all on off stage and
have to be the center of attention
however when people think that about it
I don't about Comics I don't sit there
scratching my head head wondering where
that stereotype came from you know what
I mean that's my only thing with groups
of people is like you know when you're
talking about the stereotypes of people
it would really help someone who's not
in your stereotype if you if you at
least acknowledged where it came from
like me German German Irish so I get
Nazi
alcoholic uh [__] lunatic right
whatever whatever all of it is potato
eat and
jackass um mass murder and psycho now do
I like caring that [__] I mean I I guess
I don't give a [__] but you you know
it's easy for me to say I don't give a
[__] cuz it doesn't affect my life I
don't walk into a job interview and they
go look at this [__] Nazi redheaded
[__] we're not hiring you I guess then
that would bug me
more all right you know what [__] that
whole point [__] that whole point I
guess I need to listen to people but
just some point you know what I mean it
was like after like 9/11 when they were
doing like the at the airport where they
were like anybody even remotely looked
middle middle eastern they would just
[__] you know giv them the [__] uh
they giv the business and then people
were getting mad and it's just like are
you even remotely going to
address what the [__] happened you're
going to act like you don't know where
this is coming
from 3,000 people just [__]
died that was a joke I was doing my ACT
I was like you know what if [__] 18
redheads flew two [__] bu uh planes
into the World Trade Center and knocked
them down and I went to the airport yeah
I wouldn't like getting fris every time
but I wouldn't be sitting there going oh
where is this coming from I know where
it's coming from and at some level as
much as it would be [__] annoying me
that those airport [__] were treating
me like that just because of the way
that I looked at some point I would
address the 18 redheads that [__] it
up for me [__] it up for me right does
that make any sense probably doesn't all
right let's do some reads for this week
everybody all right let's get back to oh
why did you con out on
me why did the internet con out on me
how dare you how dare
you um and this won't move why won't you
move I'm doing what I'm supposed to do
this is how you drag something all
right what do I want to talk about okay
oh the Bruins here we go Bruins here we
go BM BM 60 and
one there's 60 and one basically you
know what happened not only did they
start to get to know each other as
players I stopped watching them and ever
since I haven't been watching they've
been winning um we've gone 60 and one
the only blemish is when we played the
Philadelphia
Flyers yep they came back and [__]
tied it up and then they cl cl jiru won
it in [__] overtime but other than
that 60 And1 would you look at that and
old Don
Sweeny who I was I said at the beginning
of the year I'm like this guy the moves
this [__] guy made all right this guy
is either going to
be the next bill
bellich or he's going to be [__] run
out of town because this guy went all
in
um I I it's just every [__] thing
seems to be fallen in place I know it's
really early it would be ridiculous for
me to get overly excited about this
because when they were over 0 and three
I didn't freak out you know I was like
they looking competitive they just keep
[__] up a little bit about halfway
through the game then it became the
third perod now they're kind of nailing
it down so hopefully this is what
they're going to be doing
um but you know maybe he's more like the
Theo Epstein I have no idea all I know
is that we're competitive and I was
sitting there looking like we we we
we're going to lose to the [__]
Canadians every game again this year and
uh all of a sudden now you know who
knows who knows we'll see what happens
right Lich got his first goal for the
[__]
Kings Still bugs me to see him in that
uniform um but we got uh we got the
Dallas Stars tomorrow night
Dallas Stars Jamie Ben Tyler San Patrick
sha dude how many [__] like former
Bruins and certainly Blackhawks are
playing on number one
lines around the [__] League look
look at [__] Winnipeg with Blake
wheeler right Blake wheeler up there in
Winnipeg we got Tyler San and [__]
uh Dallas I guess Lich isn't playing on
the number one line is he no I don't
think he is but you know what that's the
greatest thing about going to daily face
off my favorite [__] website now you
know and they don't they don't pay me to
advertise for the love of [__] Christ
Bill can you learn how to drag a goddamn
window here all right and they also I
didn't realize that [__] Dallas also
has Jason spenza from [__] Ottawa is
their second line Center who knew who
knew that I didn't know that did you
know
that hey what [__] team was I just
talking about do you remember oh the
king
the Los Angeles Kings the LA [__] where
the [__] are they here we
go line combinations he is he's first
line left wing with Jeff K and Tyler
tley oh they broke up that 70 Line who
would have thought they got copar is the
center on the second one right now
you're like Jesus Bill how much hockey
are you watching I'm
not I'm not I go I just go to daily face
off and you look you click on line
combinations and you can do it Jesus how
[__] deep are they their first line
is Lich Carter and tley their second
line is Pearson
cop and Dustin Brown whenever I watch
the king I actually like the Kings
um unfuckin
believable the only thing that makes me
happy about seeing the Kings dis loaded
is it makes me it gives me hope that the
Canadians will not win a cup again this
year even though they're playing [__]
great um but anyways look at the [__]
Broz came right back
around hung in there and I got all those
games taped so I got to watch them and
I'm ridiculously excited to watch uh the
Dallas Stars game because uh they're
[__] they're you know they're one of
the best teams all of a sudden I've
always been a fan of green and white
come on I'm a Celtics fan right
um so anyways let me uh let me plow
ahead here another great thing that I
did while I was out in Chicago is I went
to arguably the greatest drum shop in
the country uh Vick's Drum Shop and
um it
is this basically
giant It's a combination Drum Shop and
like Studio space and I lost track I
think there's like four floors to
it and it almost looked like what it
used to be is you know like the one of
those places you just storage space you
know those things are really weird like
the way they set them up and there's
those narrow hallways and you walk down
them there's all of that type of stuff
so he kept all the rooms and he just
sort of combined rooms and put in
Windows so you could see through and he
has like just this symbol room he just
has like [__] and he he has like
total anal like he has every [__]
high hat you could think of and he has
him in alphabetical order so I don't
know all the drum names but he starts
with like DW and then it ends with
Yamaha every [__] kind you could
possibly ever [__] want
the remote the remote cabled ones
everyone you can think of he had this DW
double pedal that I had never even
[__] seen before they they look like
a piece of
jewelry but in glass he had another area
where it was just all uh all acoustic
drums then he had this whole area that
was all uh electronic
drums he had upstairs he had these two
monster [__]
kits like uh Terry Terry boio type
[__] I went over there with a friend of
mine he let her play on it let me play
on it it was just it was [__]
insane it was [__] insane and um and
I went into one of his drum rooms it's
nice and clean the drums were all tuned
up they sounded [__] great and what
killed me is I could have been going
down there every [__] day playing
drums when I was in Chicago instead of
being laid up [__] Hamed
I was I got so drunk at the Liars club
and if you think I'm not going back
there again and doing nine shots and
dancing the ACDC it's over like I tell
you right now Vick's Drum Shop and
[__] the Liars club I'm I'm hitting
those every time I go to town um
although next time I'm going to bring
the lovely Nia you know uh Chicago is a
um that's a I got all kinds of family
out there and you know one of the big
things all the men on um both sides of
my family would always take their wives
down to Michigan Avenue buy shoes or
whatever like throughout all of the last
century so uh that's something that I
have to do at some point I got to take I
got to take Nia down there and buy her
something but
um I could not have had a better time
and I have to tell you right now if
you're a [__] drummer I don't give a
[__] where you live if you're anywhere
there in the
midwest if you're in [__] de Mo I
don't want to hear you bitching about
the [__] the ride like if you're G to
make a major purchase
if you're going to go buy a bunch of new
symbols and all of that type of [__] I'm
telling you get in your [__] car
drive to Chicago go to vixs and I'm
telling you that guy he has
everything he had zilgon he had Sabian
he had P pasty pisty however you say
that minel he had [__] he had it all
every [__] high had just it was
insane it was [__] it was actually
like and he was going over he had a
percussion
room and he was he was going over the
whole [__] thing it was like it was
like sensory overload I almost had to
try to be like he had like a whole
[__] all all these snares this whole
room was just all snare drums hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of fuckingn
the amount of money this guy has
invested in just the [__] just to be
carrying that that amount of
inventory another cool thing he had he
had a whole
tabletop this giant table almost like an
island that you'd have in like a big
kitchen that the whole tabletop the
surface was made out of that material
that's a practice
pad so like literally like 20 drummers
could stand around it and all be just
trying out sticks and that was of course
in the stick
room I can't even like the whole [__]
thing was just it was just from top to
bottom was most insane [__] place
I've ever been to and I was just like
hey man I wanted to play you know if I
wanted how much you charge for studio
time he's like he know like 15 bucks for
an hour I can go play in a kit you know
while I'm on the [__] road that would
have been the greatest thing ever so
that's that's my one regret is that I
didn't do that three days in a row and
and get three hours better on drums or
who's kidding who I probably would have
gone there for two you got you got to do
at least two right the first hours
practice and all the [__] you suck at
and then the second hour is just playing
all your favorite songs fantasizing that
you're in the band I don't think that's
weird I think that's normal for me to do
pushing 50 years of
age so anyway so I got the Big Philly
gig the Big Philly gig coming up this
weekend and uh Friday night and um it's
going to be me Paul verie and Joe mates
Joe mates Philly native and um we're
going to be coming in there so I've been
asking the good people of Philly where I
should go to get my [__] cheese steak
you know cuz tourists like me oh go down
to gos and the other [__] place
whatever they are so I been getting all
these ideas from people and the
overwhelming
winner all right this is like an
election so you're going to know who's
winning and if you guys think I'm making
a mistake you got to send me a tweet the
overwhelming
winner as far as um not going to those
two places is is John's Roast Pork in
Philly now I know right now everybody in
Philly either went like nuts like
yes I should say people from Philly
listening to this um either went like
psyched that I'm going there or then I'm
going to get a bunch D I'll [__] go
there that place sucks so overrated I
went there it was [__] dry so John's
Roast Pork Philly I mean that sounds
delicious so I think that that's where
I'm going to go that's where I'm going
to go after the show I'm going to go
over there I'm going to stand a [__]
line as of right now unless somebody
tells me unless enough people tell me
differently that's where the [__] I'm
going um
that's where the Afterparty is going to
be I'm going to go out and get a [__]
cheese steak and you know what I can't
[__] wait I can't [__] wait that's
going to be great I just fast forward in
my
life um so anyways but like I said I'm
going to try to be a good boy here this
whole week I'm going to be working out
and doing all that type of [__] I got to
get my ass back in shape I put on
probably like s or 8 lbs over 2 weeks
maybe not that much weight it just feels
like I did but you know what I'm going
to uh I'm in town here for a good four
or 5 days before I have to go back out
again and I'm just going to eat
perfectly and work out that's what the
[__] I'm going to do that's what I'm
going to do and uh I think just from
just literally not drinking at this
point uh that alone will be enough for
me to drop a couple this week so if I
drop a good you know three four before I
do uh the Madison Square Garden one I
should be happy right um all right so
there you go so that's the uh oh did
anybody see that [__] giant Saints
game did you see the giant Saints game
it's one of the most [__] insane
games I've ever seen in my life one
quarterback throws for seven Drew Brees
Eli throws for [__] six did you
[__] you want to see you every time I
watch the Giants there's something that
reminds me not every time but a lot of
times reminds me of losing Super Bowls
to them that [__] drive that they had
the football guards love
Eli I don't ever want to see that guy
again in the playoffs
he [__] comes down the field right
they they're threatened they're down by
what were they down by they were down by
14 at that
point it was like 4228 nobody had even
attempted a [__] field goal at that
point I believe so probably hadn't punt
it either so they [__] uh whatever
they they call a pass play he drops back
to pass somebody comes right up the
middle [__] drills the guy he fumbles
the ball Saints recover this like like
13 minutes left or 12 minutes left it's
not the nail in the coffin but like if
the Saints drive down and [__] score
a touchdown or even kick a [__] field
goal they're three scores up with
probably 9 minutes left they are
ridiculously comfortable at that point
all right the defense will probably be a
little deflated cuz they sense it to the
Saints will be on their toes you know
just a game changer right football
guards step in
football God step in once again they
called some Ticky Tac
horseshit [__] uh defensive
holding right on the Saints which gives
the [__] uh
Giants the ball back and keeps the drive
going gives him like a [__] first
down they get all the way down to the
end they're on the goal
line Eli goes back to pass here comes
the [__] rush and he's rolling out
they should have sacked him but they
didn't he's rolling out and I know it's
going to happen he's going to throw the
ball and somehow it's going to land in
some giant Giant's hands so he throws
the ball back across his body running
right throws it back left with barely
anything on it classic Brett Favre six
interception game Throw throws the
[__] thing it's going to be a pick
but the guy on the Saints Miss times his
jump gets hit by another Saint lands on
his [__] head and gets a concussion
and this [__] duck just lands into
the hands of a giant for a touchdown
I've never seen a guy the the Horseshoe
that is up this guy's [__] ass I just
I looked at I was like that they're
right there if we play them again that's
how we will lose we'll lose to him just
like
that exactly to a [__] T I don't know
what it is he that guy has the [__]
magic and there's another thing too now
that I'm saying this and being a whiny
[__] [__] Patriot fan that guy also
made some some [__] sick ass throws
he's definitely I'm I'm not [__] on
the guy I [__] love him I think he's
the [__] but I have never seen a guy
[__] up so many times and and and does
not pay the price for it maybe I need to
watch him more or maybe I'm still just
so [__] rattled from those two
[__] oh my God we when we undefeated
when he threw he threw a pick to wasant
Samuel it hit him in both hands the guy
just drops it
then he throws behind his [__]
receiver the guy reaches back over the
Patriot guy's arm and catches it with
his hand in his
helmet [__] I I mean just anybody
else that'd be an incomplete pass you
[__] up as a
quarterback or it would be it' be a pick
I'm telling you I i' I've I've never
[__] seen it it's just it's insane I
never want to see that guy if we play
the Giants in the Super Bowl this year
I'm telling you right now I'm not going
to watch it or I'll watch the first 3/4
and then I'm just walking away and I'm
going to stand outside my party and just
waiting for the screams of
Agony I know it's going to happen what
the [__] when that happens I'm just
going to [__] I'm just going to walk
away going to walk away I'm not going to
watch ESPN for like a month I'm I you
know I might even take a month off of my
podcast I didn't want to [__] see it
I'm telling you this guy he sold his
soul something happened isn't that right
Cleo come here get over here buddy get
up on the
ouch what do you say there buddy huh
what do you
say want to hear listen to
this you never do the [__] moan when
I give you the hug she does a sing I
come up she give her a hug she
goes you stink buddy you know that I'm
going to give you a bath you want a bath
oh there's the look why don't dogs like
getting baths you know what I mean they
hate the process but then afterwards
they [__] freak out
I can't tell if it's cuz they feel good
or they just psych that it's over but
it's almost like watching a junkie just
keep using rather than just going if you
just go through a little bit of
misery you know you're going to be all
right
huh all right let's read some letters
CLE you want to chime in on some of
these all right cross country
lady um hey maybe I can get ni up here
she hasn't done the podcast in a minute
hang on one second hold
on well no such luck I thought she was
downstairs where is she Cleo all right
cross country lady uh Bill I'm a
25-year-old girl um you're a woman
you're a lady I'm pretty responsible and
competent and don't whine like some brds
over there I'm not one of those girls
who can say they know how to change a
tire but I've done enough that I think I
could if I had to yeah you can change a
tire you got to change a tire but nobody
can change a [__] tire with the
factory Jack that they Jack Jack handle
that they give you you can't get enough
[__] torque unless you're just some
[__] you got those Popeye
forearms what you really need is you
just need a little piece of pipe that
you can stick over you know you loosen
the lugs while it's still on the
ground then as you go to Jack it up you
stick your spare underneath the tire
underneath the [__] frame in case it
comes crashing down that's supposed to
save you but the [__] thing so God
damn small now it doesn't matter all
right you take the [__] off you put
the new one on all right you put all the
[__] lugs on that you put in your
pocket or in a place you didn't none of
them rolled away and then you lower the
car back down and then you tighten and
you go it's the easiest [__] thing
ever right all right that's the attitude
right uh on a somewhat related but
unrelated note I'm looking to drive
across the country I'm moving to Los
Angeles from Rhode Island my parents are
cool and trust me but they have their
concerns about me driving by myself yeah
absolutely you've you've seen this great
country from all your touring I suspect
early on in your comedy career there was
more driving than flying absolutely
there was uh do you have any advice or
Warnings against me doing so I would
take a week or so and pick out some
different stops I drive a 2003 black
Volvo station wagon it's ready to go so
am I what are your
thoughts uh PS thanks for checking in on
us on Thursday it really means a lot um
all right what would my advice be uh my
advice
my advice would actually be to maybe do
it with somebody else just because um
especially depends on where you're
staying you know as a woman going out
there by yourself I would definitely
stay at nice hotels enough underground
parking uh you know just really well-lit
places don't do what I did where I
[__] I drove across country in about
2 and A2 days one time my T my big
Square 1990s TV in the back and I would
just pull up to shitty hotels and I
would just sleep in the car cuz I didn't
want to drag all my [__] out of the car
into the thing so I just slept there
like a [__] idiot someone would have
broke the window by the time I realized
what was going on my throat would have
been slit so I would I would do it with
somebody else um if you're going to go
during the winter time you want to get
South as quick as you
can um maybe go across the 40 hey Nene
you want to come on the podcast I'm I
eat breakfast oh you eat breakfast yes
can you say hello to everybody hi
everybody all
right um so I would maybe do the 40 as
opposed to the 70 um the 70 is beautiful
when you drive across uh I believe that
one it goes it actually goes south of
Pittsburgh but you go through
um like I my favorite part of the 70 is
actually when you first pick it up is
that the 15 the 15 goes up and meets the
70 from the West well Bill why don't you
take a [__] map out going through
Utah um wait I got to reread it you go
to Los Angeles yeah so if you take the
70 across going through Utah going
through
Vegas going through the Rocky Mountains
is this amazing tunnel that you drive
through um as you get out towards Grand
Junction and all of that I will tell you
what is a [__] is after uh I
mean you got to do the thing where you
you you
you go through St Louis you know and you
see the arch that's the
[__] um and it's cool right until you
get to Kansas City stop in Kansas City
get yourself some barbecue and then just
[__] settle in because Kansas is a
[__]
um that's a [__] trying to get
through that thing uh although you know
if the j-hawks have a game I'd stop
maybe have yeah if you figure out [__]
that you want to do along the way you
can have a great time but I got to be
honest with you if you were my sister or
my my daughter or whatever I would not
want you doing it by yourself um but if
you are going to do it by yourself just
make sure you stay in safe places Keep
Your Head on a [__] swivel and I
would also uh the second you get tired
pull over I mean get to your destination
don't do the dumb [__] that I did where
you're almost like hallucinating I got a
buddy of mine a comedian told me a story
he's the one who cured me of it he was
[__] driving to the airport nod off
like early in the morning and next thing
he he woke up he was laying in a
field he got thrown from the [__] car
and somehow just landed in the field and
was okay and uh he wasn't wearing a seat
Bel
obviously by the way did you guys see
that kid out here in Los Angeles this
poor kid like 20 years old was driving
lost control of his car the thing was
rolling he got ejected out of the car
and you know those signs on the free
freeway that the trucks that 18 wheelers
can drive underneath without hitting he
went up hit that thing and landed you
know sometimes they have like a little
walkway up there his body landed up
there um so I would say be careful
definitely be careful
um where the [__] is all the rest of the
questions
here for this week that's what I would
say oh look who's
here you decided to show up Cleo for the
love of [__] Christ you got to do
every every week I can't get through the
podcast without the thing you just love
unplugging [__] don't you come
here all right come here n help me with
these last few uh these last few
questions I don't know what just
happened to them I had a bunch of
questions and they all went away
live
content oh I don't even know when that
one was
from all right here we go
Royals you don't want to talk sports do
you can you grab another microphone
though yeah
hang on let's see
here you can plug it
in here can you grab a microphone and
I'll plug it it I think it's somewhere
in my bag J either that yeah we'll
probably have to share one
sorry hang on hang on hang on hang on
sorry pluging in pluging
in where
is all right with the magic of the pause
button here we go all right Nia we're
going to talk sports with you Oh goodie
the Royals where are they
from Cincinnati no wait wait good guess
though it's one of those cities one of
those B so-called B level cities I don't
know wait wait no no I don't know they
have great
Barbecue Kansas City bam Billy bats I
know you're touring and you didn't get
to see much baseball but I just want to
say how much I like Harold
Reynolds you know Harold Reynolds right
it's a huge difference having a guy who
can explain baseball I know baseball but
uh it's the Insight you want to hear
this was a great World Series uh don't
know what the ratings were but this was
the best baseball I've seen in a while
despite the fact that the Mets were
lucky to be there based on their record
and slow start to the season what the
[__] does that mean what do you mean
lucky to be there you don't get lucky
getting in the World Series you won the
games you had to win the Royals played
really excited baseball hits are more
fun than home runs any day thanks for
the podcast all right I guess he's just
saying he likes Harold Reynolds that's
really not a question um no I was like
you know what's really cool was of
course you know this to see George Brett
excited like a fan when he saw them all
run out you know the great George Brett
last guy who came the closest to hitting
400 okay he hit 400 like through August
almost he ended up with at
390 um all right Halloween drama here we
go Nene you were home for Halloween yes
I was uh
Bill you're really bringing it this week
you are really bringing you didn't get
any breakfast yes I was Halloween is a
date in October yes it is all right bill
I'll cut right to the chase I was at a
Halloween party and naturally tons of
girls were dressed scantily clad my
girlfriend's costume though uh though a
bit revealing was extremely tasteful
compared to other broads so I see this
dude taking pictures of girls asses and
just being a creep about it yeah
absolutely yeah so I look at him as if
to say what the [__] are you doing he
just walked away a couple minutes later
I see him snapping a picture that was
framing my girlfriend's tits albeit they
were covered and not hanging out it was
a creep still a creep move so I stepped
in front of him and confronted him yep
he said it's a party everyone's everyone
takes pictures a couple people looked at
me funny like I was an overprotective
douche what no the thing is I opened my
mouth before it even involved my
girlfriend did I do something wrong of
course
not well no and that's the thing about
it it's it's like I feel like it's women
can say over and over again don't take
pictures of me you know stop Ling at me
stop being a [__] disgusting
perverted creep but it's going to take
guys like you and other guys to say to
other guys like that's not cool like
stop taking pictures of these girls
unless they're like posing for pictures
for you right I think I think don't take
pictures of my girlfriend don't do that
I don't care if it's a party I don't
care that happened to me one time I went
to some bar club or something and I was
dancing with my girlfriends and this
dude came and was like trying to video
the entire thing of us dancing together
and I was like I just stopped and I put
my hand in front of his face and I was
like don't do that he was like well you
freaking out about M everyone's just
like taking pictures it's cool it's cool
I said no it's not cool you're not
allowed to take pictures of me stop
taking pictures of me and then finally
he just kind of like turned away and I'm
sure he well when you're in public he
actually is allowed but you still just
tell him stuff mean he is allowed he's
allowed if you want you in public you're
considered in public and it's it's on
you that doesn't but it doesn't make it
okay it's the new cell phone era it's
it's I don't but there's no rule that
says you're allowed to just take there's
no rues saying you can't do we need to
talk
about sorry I knocked the plug out we're
back here here's the thing the like with
the with cell phones now like all of
that type of stuff you can tell somebody
not to do it but they can't be
prosecuted or anything for doing it once
you're out in
public uh you're considered in public
and people can take pictures of you h
like the paparazzi they just follow
famous people around they take [__]
pictures of them and everything they
can't go like into their house or go
onto their property then they're
considered trespassing but the second
you walk out there well here's my
question to you I don't think obviously
I don't think that someone should
[__] take pictures that's definitely
creepy but as far as the learing thing
goes do you think women have any
responsibility as far as if you're going
to go out there and and dress
suggestively aren't do they have any
respon
responsibility I think that if you go
out and you're dressed in a revealing
way I think yes of course naturally
people are going to look at you but it
doesn't give anybody the right
to say nasty things to you or to touch
you or to think that they just have I'm
not talking about touching I'm just
saying somebody's staring at you see I
knew you're G to get mad no I knew you
going to get mad I'm just saying like
it's it's like
do you if you don't want that to happen
to you right and I can wear whatever the
[__] I want to wear that's the bottom
line so can I I can walk down the street
make wearing a [__] suit made out of
dollar bills and then when I get hit
over the head and mugged I'm going to be
like I should be allowed to blah blah
blah there's like the way you wish the
world could be and the way it really is
I agree but I don't think that anyone
should feel like they have access to you
on those levels just because of what
you're wearing it's still not right
absolutely it's it's not right but my
[__] saying the same thing I know but
my thing is is you know that there's
creeps out there m you know that there's
animals out there why would you put
yourself in the crosshairs of them
because I well because it's not about
them it's about what I or the person
wants to wear yeah and so if I want to
go out and wear something sexy cuz I'm
feeling myself then I'll go out and wear
something sexy and I would expect that
people would look at me sure but would I
expect them to start like taking
pictures and [__] no I'm not saying
pictures I'm saying the learing thing
like as a guy you're going to get looks
on the guy side of it is when a woman
shows up with their tits hanging out M
okay and you look at her tits and then
she gets mad we're always like well
[__] put them away and then it's
always like well I should have a right
to have my tits out they're my tits you
know and then we we get yelled at like
where these [__] lunatics and it's
almost like like that in in policing
that's like entrapment well I think
there well first of all no one's [__]
thinking about you all right you're not
[__] Mary and Barry this isn't
entrapment okay so yes
looking just standing there like the
entire time it's like I start feeling
[__] creeped out and weirded out and
unsafe so have your look and keep it
moving okay so that's definitely fair
have your look and keep it moving I love
it that's the rule so let me ask you
this but don't try to invade my space
and try to get into my head and all that
kind of [__] like don't do that have
your look keep it moving all right
here's my question for you what's the
difference what what's the time we'll
put a shot clock on this you know in the
NBA you got a 24 second shot clock the
difference between having your look and
learing how how how many seconds before
your a shot clock violation and you turn
over the
ball um I think anything
beyond 5 Seconds 5 seconds is a great
look yeah 5 Seconds should do it the old
up and
down nice maybe little smile keep it
moving all right now that took less than
5 Seconds even to describe all that well
so I I think five you want to hear 5
Seconds I'll show you 5 Seconds he's
looking in 1 2 3 four five so someone
can look at you that long yeah that's
good that's all right yeah that's fine
that's fine you're a hot [__] all right
five
seconds any ladies out there if you want
to you want to add some time to that you
want to shave some off that that is the
kind of thing that that guys though cuz
listen sometimes you know what's the
worst thing is when you're not a [__]
pervert but the woman's gorgeous and
she's wearing something so revealing and
then she comes at you like you're a
[__] creep and you're just like
you're wearing a cats
suit like what am I I'm not supposed to
[__]
look
okay that's that right that's what I'm
yeah you can it's like I keep saying
look and keep it
moving that's it
it does have to be this whole [__]
thing where you're like staring and
panting and by staring you're trying to
get my attention so that I react it's
like if you're going to stare and then I
catch you staring just sorry for staring
you just you you look beautiful thank
you moving on there you go and then what
if he he tries to talk to you I mean you
know what's he supposed to do you look
good he wants to [__] uh you know
thank you keep it
moving Jesus Christ yeah you can't well
what if he wants to ask you what what if
you know what if you were
single I mean you know what well it
depends if I'm interested in like
continuing the conversation or whatever
then yes let's continue the conversation
but in all aspects you got to like wait
for like the opening to appear you can't
just force the
opening that sounds gross you know what
I
mean I don't we're like door to-door
salesman single guys we just we have to
like [__] just knock on the door yeah
hey how you doing up Bill I really like
to have some affection okay thank you
hey how you doing yeah and that's the
thing about it it's like guys act like
you know it's you it's not like the
[__] end of the world like you know
10 seconds later you're talking and
looking at somebody else so what is the
big deal about moving on if there's not
like the person saying like bre yet and
your music [__] break I can't I can't
get mad at any of this 5sec look keep it
moving if I give you a look like I want
to keep talking these are really basic
ideas you know what I mean it is it's
really it's really basic it's some wants
to talk to you that they'll continue
talking to you oh thank you so much oh
are are you here with friends boom you
and now let me ask you this have you
ever been out with a friend who's
wearing something so revealing and
they're getting so much of that
attention they're complaining about it
have you ever said to them like well
maybe you should have put the girls away
a little more you know maybe you should
have brought the garage door down a
little bit more no you've never said
that no I've never said that to any of
my girlfriends have you ever thought it
you've ever felt it no you've never had
a roommate or a girlfriend just show up
and be like oh my God her hooa is almost
peeking out from underneath that dress
this is oh I'll tell you this going to
be a rough one like you know all these
dogs you never think that I have to be
honest with you though I I don't think
that most of my
girlfriends dress revealingly okay so if
you seen some that you don't know have
you seen somebody that you don't know
show up at a club okay with like you
know body paint on in a pair of pasties
and just go like am I at carnival huh
like what is she doing you know what I'm
talking about I'm just asking do women
also look at the woman yes and look at
her and be like what is that idiot
doing um yeah probably mhm I think
that's a yes but for some reason you're
not going to give it to me cuz I'm a guy
well no I don't think that's it I think
there's definitely been times where
you're just like really girl really okay
all right and that's that's that's about
it
really okay okay that's fine okay that's
not a good answer or like if I see a
girl wearing shorts that are like like
denim shorts that are basically fitting
you like underwear I feel like that's a
little
extra to have your ass hanging out but
if a girl wants to walk around with her
ass hanging out it's like I'm not it
doesn't trip me out but I do personally
feel like it's a little bit much why is
that but I'm also getting older so I'm
getting a little bit more conservative
cuz I don't need to see your ass cheeks
girl need to see that but it's not a lot
of times I will ConEd that it's not NE
it's not for me it's not even
necessarily for guys it's for her so
despite how I might feel about wait wait
despite the way I might feel about how
she's dressed that is her decision to be
dressed how she's dressed and guess what
it doesn't ruin my whole day and it
doesn't send me into this Tail Spin of
like oh my God I don't understand these
girls are walking around half naked and
I'm not supposed to look like wh where 5
Seconds keep it moving no but here's my
thing do you understand how [__]
ridiculous it is to walk down the street
with your ass hanging out I do
understand how ridiculous stupid is I do
think it's ridiculous I think it's too
much but again it's not my [__] thing
to get upset about what somebody else is
wearing you funny you know what's funny
it's not my business when I drive down
the street being an ass man if a woman
has her ass hanging out I'm psyched I
got like a free show yes exactly and
that classic thing there that classic
thing where like how guys can't do that
there's nothing we could do like
physically like that that makes you guys
almost crash your car this is a hacky
joke but if we were walking down the
street with half our nutbag hanging out
you'd be like be
gross cuz that's not sexy we're anim I
know we're animals it's not sexy a
woman's ass can be sexy her breast her
legs her whole body is just like curvy
and delicious and the whole a guy with B
bag hanging out is disgusting and you
want to call the police yeah yeah if it
was a car like the woman's like a a
Lamborghini or a Ferrari or a por like
how many women flashers do you know like
have you ever heard of a woman like
going into a place and exposing her GS
to like a room full of men running out
as creepy as that
is I I flashers are the funniest [__]
thing ever to me the fact that they you
know the the classic one with the
[__] wing tip shoes the dark socks
and just the rank coat on and you just
throw open your [__] coat showing
your flaccid dick or whatever to me and
then people are
horrified like the reaction that you get
it's like traumatic it's [__] weird
but that's that's the funny thing about
it is that you would think that you
you're doing something cuz in the end
you wanted to get a positive reaction
but to [__] throw it open and people
Lally repulse like when you do that
looking at your naked body the fact that
they get off on that is [__]
hilarious to me it's it's so it's it's
gross it's just a dick G just it's a
dick outside you know wants to be free
yeah it's like no no it doesn't it
doesn't want to be free it doesn't need
to be free keep it tucked away in your
little Underpants and you know I can
understand most fetishist that was the
for the life of me I don't get what are
you do what are you doing then you do
that and then what you jerk off to the
scream still ringing in your
head is that what they do I don't know I
don't know it's just I don't even know
if they do it when I was on living I
don't think that they do it like I think
Hollywood made it be the raincoat
because they couldn't show a dick on
film for whatever reason so they just
had the guy go like that so would block
all of it you just see his naked legs
and you it was understood that he was
naked but I think really it's for the
most part it's probably sweatpants and
they probably yank them down and then
they have it right underneath their junk
and they
go all right all right all right okay
that's
gross I remember being in a New York
City subway car and this guy started
masturbating in front of me and I ran
out and I was pretty much in tears it
was so upsetting and it was just so it's
like it's violating you know just
someone staring at you and just being
like why are you laughing it's not funny
it was really
upsetting see you don't [__] get it I
know I I think you should have laughed
at him and pointed right at his well
that's exactly what he wanted he wanted
to like me to keep like watching it and
like no he wanted you to be [__]
shocked at with I don't know either
either way either either way was just
horrifying and it felt like it felt
terrible it was like it was it was a
real violation of me you know like you
can't just like see a stranger and just
start jerking off what the take a mental
picture keep it moving get home and then
rub one out yeah like gentle for your
Dirty Studio roach infested apartment
well why just cuz he jerks off on the
train doesn't mean he can't be
successful 9 to5 I don't really care
about his his success if he feels the
need to jerk off and maybe he's one of
those guys he's like you are not a
success you are a
failure I got to think afterwards after
you're done doing it like at some point
when you come home and you're brushing
your teeth and you look yourself in the
mirror you got to be like well I'm that
guy I'm that guy that jerks off the
people on the trait I'm sure they hate
themselves and they
should
look at Cleo half on the bed half off
and I'm sitting over here like what do
you want what do you want from me all
right Halloween drama okay yeah so
getting back to that thing he didn't do
something wrong the other guy's a
[__] creep yeah you should definitely
like interject when [__] like that is
going on and let other men know that's
not cool all right hologram
comedians hey Breaking Bad Bill have you
heard that a comedy club in New York
might showcase Carlin and prior
Holograms okay I mean I don't I don't
get that that's [__] weird that's
like a live week to me why I don't
understand the point of it's so stupid
just go home go home and it's going to
be material you've already seen so all
you got to do is you just go home and
you just put in the DVD I would like to
have been there for that Tupac hologram
at Coachella a couple years ago that
would have been interesting only because
you know you're probably like on a ton
of drugs at Coachella and stuff like
that so you're just like like there are
all these videos of people like
recording it you know on their phone and
you hear people in the background going
I knew it and people be like I told you
I told like he was actually alive and
then they're like oh no wait it's a you
know what I don't like about it what I
don't like about it is Tupac didn't
agree to do the gig he didn't agree on
the money who owns the rights to his
likeness his mom probably and she
probably gave it the okay can I tell you
oh really what is that the after school
special version of entertainment I'll
tell you right now I bet I'm I'm going
right now in in in the future
in the future I bet all dead celebrities
like like [__] scumbag people in this
business will own their likeness they'll
somehow trick their [__] next to
whoever into [__] selling the rights
to them and they'll still have these
people touring and they're put together
like these these hologram fantasy teams
and and they'll make money off of these
people and and their loved ones won't
get any of the cash that's what I'm
that's going to be the lawsuit in the
next 20 years
that uh a dead [__] George Carlin
went on tour and grossed $20 million or
something like that and none of his next
to Ken got any
money and then some [__] little piece
of [__] will have no comment yeah you
don't think so that's what I think about
I hope that doesn't
happen of course it will they they
already [__] they've been you they
started using them in in commercials
they had like a dead John Wayne selling
like [__] an Xbox or something it's
[__] ridiculous
all right cross country watch some here
we go cross country oh I already did
that one oh this lady said really
quickly uh she was saying she's a
25-year old girl and she's uh going to
be moving across the country she's
driving LA to uh Los Angeles she's
driving the car by herself obviously get
the whole [__] thing please be
careful yeah right that's what I was
saying I I said she should do it with
somebody
else I mean yeah she'll be she'll be
able to handle it she'll be she'll be
all right just be careful yeah just make
sure that car is running
perfectly and you know make sure you
don't stop in any sketchy [__] motels
it always makes me think of your bit
about um murderer Buffet what did you
call it serial killer buffet serial
killer buffet the motel they just the
ground Flor well your door opens up to
the parking lot the serial killer buffet
I'm killing this guy I'm killing that
guy that one's all right yeah you stay
in that [__] hotel from uh No Country
for Old Men all right legal zo everybody
I got to do a couple of uh you want to
listen me do the reads and then sign off
sure all right Jesus uh legalism
everybody somewhere along the L know I
pissed you off in that the flasher thing
mhm you did I no I don't know just in
general just just an in general
annoyance of me yep but please really
read your read your ads I come back off
a two We Tour conquering [__] God you
I was so happy to within 24 [__]
hours you're already sick of me that's
what you're saying
un [__] you know what Nia if you ever
leave if you ever leave me I'm for the
rest of my life I'm just be that guy I'm
going to have dogs I'm going to have
dogs and I'm going to go down to a
massage parlor every day get one rubbed
out and I'm going to be good for the
rest of the day dogs and the [__] NHL
package tell my jokes that's it your
lawyer goes to call me I'll be what do
what does she want what does old Sweetie
Cakes want huh don't talk about that
don't say
that you dumb bowl of oatmeal is that
oatmeals that Sugar corn smacks no it's
uh steel cuties granola that has dried
banana in it for some [__] reason all
right legalism you don't like bananas I
don't like the texture I hate when you
say that it's always a food that I like
and then you why don't you like it the I
don't like the texture you're such a
narcissist that I can't even not like a
certain food and you get offended by it
like who what do you care if I don't
like certain words I don't like I don't
like annoys me why bill I don't like
texture who says that it's a legitimate
thing I don't like the texture of banana
it feels weird in my mouth it's not a
sofa it's a [__] piece of food okay
texture can refer to things that aren't
just like furniture furniture all
right I just hated it I don't like the
texture like you're some food critic
just be happy God made it and eat it
good look legal
some tell say that say that someday
someday in the afternoon yeah you're
going to go you go meet God you tell us
you know it's my had a great time thank
for like by the way can you work on the
banana thing I I didn't like the texture
this isn't like a human being a godamn
monkey ban throwing a bunch of different
combinations all natural so what like
your weed man I don't have to like weed
is oh yeah well that's a good thing hey
it's good to see you yeah you too it is
good to see you I'm psych to be home f j
off oh Jesus all right I like how you
shout into a microphone which is
designed to project your voice Lou than
actually is I pull my my head away I'm a
master at using the microphone if you
actually took the time to watch one of
my sets one time oh please and you watch
the E and and you watch the EB and flow
do I bring that crowd up I push him away
yeah it's a real emotional Journey that
you take my dick jokes have three act to
them you know what Nia I was so excited
to see you and I still am and for you to
sit here coming back and I'm not I'm not
feeling the love from you you still look
cute who that knows huh thank you no I'm
excited to have you back you've been
gone for two weeks it's great that
you're home you sound like you're
reading a statement from for a
corporation we are excited to have him
back uh he gone for two week have you
back we uh still haven't gotten all the
information so we can't comment on
anything else at this time right exactly
you look at that goddamn dog that thing
slept 8 hours last night I literally
walked it around the block gave it food
and it is just out like a light it's
right now people it's it's on its dog
bed 3/4 of it dog it body is on the dog
bed and then like its head and neck is
off looks like it passed out like it
fainted all right that's the podcast for
this week thank you to everybody uh for
listening and uh Hey Nia you're a huge
cheese steak fan right I love cheese
steak I love cheese steak I don't like
the way my favorite sandwich I felt like
you were learing at it just look at the
sandwich and keep it moving keep it
moving you're like I love cheese steaks
it's my favorite sandwich in the whole
world is a Philly cheese steak do you
have to say Philly cheese steak or can
you just say cheese steak they just say
when you're in Philly you say cheese
steak but everywhere else when when
you're in [__] uh France you just
order onion soup you know go can I get
french onion soup they're like well
you're in French you [__] idiot so
everything here is going to be french
onion
soup I guess that's true actually oh
whatever okay um everyone's telling me
to go to John's Roast Pork for and
doesn't that just sound good the name oh
it's a it's a place to eat yeah cuz what
are the two what are the two touristy
places it's gos and what
else oh I forget Gino and Rabino wites
yep
chinos oh wait Philly yeah there's the
two they're right next to each other
places right yeah hang on hang
on Gino
stakes and
uh and then the other
one I don't know how to look it up and I
can't do it with one [__] hand even
but even those were good last time me
and ver went there we we got we both got
stood in line he stood in one I stood in
the other we got one of each cut him in
half and then oh did like a a taste test
yeah all right top 10 spots are you are
you willing to reveal which one you
liked
better um oh Pats all right so one of
them had a better cheese I I can never
remember this [__] do you get or I like
the bread better
I don't like whiz I like real cheese me
too I like the real Cheese look how
[__] good those look this is thing
too you guys going to understand out
here they just don't have good delies
they can't make good it's a dry air or
something they can't make good bread the
sandwiches the
[__] downtown that uh pastrami place
that's supposed to be really good in
Downtown LA I forget the name of it they
talked about it on that show The
Comedians oh okay you know with Josh Gad
and um yeah you mean that [__]
brilliant show that I absolutely love
that they not bring it back for some
[__] up Reas cancel that show yeah it
sucks I love that show listen I got to I
got to upload this cuz I got to get on
with the day here hour and 25 minutes
huh cuz you stuck around all right
everybody go [__] yourselves I'll check
in on you on
Thursday what's up everybody and welcome
back to the anything better podcast NFL
Edition for week number nine with your
host Paul ver over here Bill Burr over
there Andrew Paul ver over here over
here guys we're into week number nine
sponsored by our favorites B MGM it's
the B MGM app everybody it's the best
app it's the best lines out there what
do you do to get it all you do is you
download the app you put as little as
$10 into the account and you will get up
to $200 in bets regardless of the
outcome of your first wager it's an
incredible deal please bet responsibly
here's how it works you download the app
you use our code the anything better
code which is burr2 200 B
rr200 and put as little as $10 in you
also have a Survivor pool where you
could pick a team not against the spread
just have that team win and you keep
going every week so on and so forth and
until you lose and then you're done but
there are still prizes for that as well
um yeah man let's get into this dude
that was a great read Paul you look
right near the camera right in Mr Mrs
America I thought that was fantastic
look dude you know something when you
when you're a pro you're a pro yeah you
know Paul you know they can't teach what
you just did hey who am I
um dude how about the Texas
Rangers I know I know did you watch any
of that series it was I mean it was just
fun to W I mean it what mean they kind
of blew through them but uh I'm really
happy man I'm really happy for Texas
Rangers fans they've been what dude that
that's the old Washington Senators they
moved in 1962 or or came back in 62
that's right after the the original
Senators moved to Minnesota and became
the twins yeah who the most [__] up
things ever the Senators left from lack
of support and then they gave them the
Senators again a different Senators like
the Cleveland Browns became the Ravens
but even the Cleveland had to way I'm
doing Rainman [__] here Paul I'm just
saying I'm happy for the Rangers I don't
know what's going on with my camera look
like I have the flu and poison ivy it's
nice to see a team like the Rangers win
what was not nice to see was two of our
pitchers that we dumped were on this on
their staff so uh you know you're just
watching X Yan we had one of them we had
one of them too yeah he came to Boston
first is anything worse is anything
worse than watching a team celebrate a
championship when players were on your
team earlier in that season I hate that
I'm like it doesn't bug me it does that
doesn't bug me though listen they they
don't want to [__] pay him yeah right
so they understand now that that that
that they don't care about them so they
bouncing around the league that's just
the way it is you know what I do I see
love them when they're with you you're
happy when they win somewhere else hey
mie bets go good good on you we should
have paid you we didn't you know what I
do when I see an ex Yankee or an ex Nick
winning somewhere else I just go there
he is just makes me there he is guys the
foul there he is Guy our guy he is um he
was in grade school with us dude look at
him all grown up winning a championship
I gotta tell you something man I gotta
talk about this on the show it's one of
the most disappointing Giants losses me
and my son watched D Lucas was dude 29
seconds left and we were so dominant
defensive
and our kicker just miss a 30 Y and we
go to overtime and lose I mean it was a
rough one against the Jets oh well Paul
I gotta tell you something right now
like that [__] I bet the Ravens last
week okay like I had to go for a walk
after that loss yeah I am like uh that
that took my heart
like I'm all right with
it no what am I gonna say that my wife
runs around on me I'm like that [__]
guy in that joke right now as a gambler
like I was just Paul in the first half I
have the [__] Ravens laying eight and
a half I think I had eight and a half
other people had nine and a half I have
eight and a half I mean who am I Paul
nice I'm getting a point in my favor
right yeah Ravens gonna [__] kill him
right Arizona comes out like Gang
Busters playing great they're beating
him in the first half I could have
handled that Paul that happens who saw
the Broncos beating the Chiefs I mean
just every once in a while the underdog
just comes up shows up to play and the
other guys you know they just lose I can
handle that yeah Paul what I can't
handle
is it as an American I'm watching the
game of the week I'm watching [__]
Joe burrow in the Bengals right healthy
Joe burrow the 49 you know and I'm
looking at the ticker holy [__] [__]
Ravens come back they're up by 20 15 or
something like that I'm oh my God I'm
gonna go two and two I'm not like they
were so up Paul I stopped watching the
ticker and I'm just enjoying how great
the Bengals are playing it was a great
game against the 49ers unless you're a
49ers fan and then the game ends Paul
they just click over and the Cardinals
are lining up for a field goal Ravens
are up by 10 and there's like I don't
know few seconds left I'm going what the
[__] is this what happened what happened
Paul evidently they they score a
touchdown they kick an onside [__]
kick they recover it so now they line up
so the guy kicks the ball Paul and it
goes wide Oh Billy freckles two and two
baby flag on the play oh
flag on the [__] play and because it
was before the Whistle the the uh the
Ravens couldn't decline it they back it
up five they give him a breakfast ball
and he goes up there and he
kicks it just inside the upright [__]
you freckles [__] your dreams I and [__]
whatever you wanted to do in this dude I
literally when I was sending you those
text Paul I was in my backyard and I was
walking in a [__] Circle oh dude I
was getting text from Bill and he was
you know what's funny is that night Bill
a Thursday night the same thing I got
the I had the Bucks and I'm going I'm
gonna be 0 and one on Thursday anything
worse than being 0 and one on Thursday
and all of a sudden I got the back door
cover at the last second and I was like
all
right but I know that sucks dude the
feel listen that'll happen to you once
or twice a year but no no no no Paul I
don't want to hear that I can take a
lost like a [__] man okay what
happened in Phoenix Arizona was wrong
I tweeted I'm want to start a support
group like dude that's one of those ones
because you know what it was Paul yeah I
counted it as a win in my head I know
it's I know I was going down Bourbon
Street Paul I had the [__] baton I
was [__] high kicking down the street
the trophy was coming out of the locker
room like the Spurs in game six the wire
was off the champagne bottle we had the
goggles on and then somebody said hey
hey hey wait a second wait a second it's
not even hey wait a second you lost wait
a second you're now going to watch them
you're going to watch yourself win again
with the Miss field goal and then
there's G to be a flag that looked a lot
like a tissue for you to cry in
ironically enough and then he kicked
some [__] knuckle ball that looked
like they they draged some guy out of
the crowd and they old punt pass and
kick [__] H yeah I know so Paul I'm G
I'm just going to tell you right now I
am a I I am I'm a one-wing bird this
week I don't know what's up I don't know
what's down I have no [__] idea okay
I'm I don't love the lines dude and I'm
looking at Americans right now do not
listen to me this we all right do you
mean you had one I think you had one you
dude you had like two one or two bad
what are you nuts what do you mean one
of my nuts Paul this happens to me every
year in October do you know what
gambling is over an entire football
season for me it's like playing golf I
give a [__] for the first whole four
holes then I just start going what the
[__] am I doing here you know uh um
you're holding on too all right go ahead
bill you too
tight too tight H you're holding on too
tight H all right you get first pick
this week bill you know what I I should
have had like a glass of wine right
there I sounded like some woman trying
to get over her [__] last boyfriend
all right I got first pick Paul hey and
you know me you know me Paul when I got
first pick you think I'm going to
[__] act like I don't where the hell
are my pics here oh this is more [__] to
okay here we go here we go bet
MGM bet
MGM they're going to call me and just be
like you know I understand you're
talking about the emotion but try to
make gambling seem more fun I'm gonna
take the Minnesota Vikings on the road
laying four why not against the against
the Falcons I think the Falcons had
their moment this is what I think Paul I
know the exact opposite thing's going to
happen but I'm going to take the Vikings
you know why Paul because I like the
color purple I like the movie The Color
Purple I liked Prince my daughter likes
the color purple I just think they have
prettier
uniforms all right I don't like the
Falcons how they they they they just put
on black because Jerry Glenville wanted
to seem like you know his dick was an
inch longer than it really was you know
they they were a red team they were red
and gray all the way back to the great
William Andrews Billy White Shoes
Johnson Steve Bartowski RC thielman go
ahead all right I I like this game all
week I don't love the half a point but
I'm going to take it I I still don't
believe in the
Jets uh I think the Jets are a bad team
I think the Giants let him off the hook
and should have won that game the
Chargers are starting to roll the
Chargers got Eckler back Austin Eckler
is back I think the Chargers it's three
and a half I [__] hate the half a
point if it was three I would take it to
the bank today
Paul you know I hate when you have Hate
in Your Heart uh I'm GNA take you can't
do that Paul I'm friends with you
because you you you have this spirit
that I want that's what I get out of
this relationship so when I see you
start to act like me it makes me lose
hope uh I'm G take the Los Angeles
Chargers going into New York Jets and
winning that game by more than three
they're more they [__] do a wait wait
they beat the [__] out of the Bears
didn't they I like that they're coming
in thereat the bears but they also got
Eckler they're starting to come into
their own I think they're getting
healthy I I think their defense is good
enough and I just I know the Jets have a
great defense the Jets don't have a
quarterback man I just don't think the
Jets don't have the thing I think I
think the Chargers have better uniforms
would you say that I would say that and
I would also the fashion level too if
the Chargers win the game they get to F
they get to 500 and I think they're
gonna get to 500 and I think this is a
team that they could get to 500 over so
Chargers have better looking fans I have
better looking fans right I mean jets
are animals yeah beautiful Stadium you
know you Jet fans they come out from
underneath the Port Authority Justin
fans work with their hands and sometimes
fall in their faces and Justin Herbert's
got a nice head of hair he's six foot
six goodlooking kid when a charger fan
falls on his face it's usually off a
surfboard it's a nice soft Landing pole
I was thinking the surfboard yeah kissed
by the sun Paul verzy for the win right
Chargers La charges I like it uh I'm
going to take the uh I'm going to take
the uh the [__] Houston Texans minus
two and a half because my agent told me
you know my agent's a big time Gambler
you know he's got real estate he's got
money hidden in the floors of all of his
all of his buildings that he owns you
know I'm in debt with him so it's minus
two and a half they're playing the
Buccaneers they're both three and
four uh that adds up to a six and eight
record collectively and I like that I
like when two three and four teams play
each other pul and it adds up to a six
and eight overall record when two three
and four teams with collectively it adds
up to six and eight play each other in
the first week of November historically
bald jingers win that bet so I'm taking
the Texans minus two and a half all
right I like how you blew all of that
off like that any of that made sense no
no I'm just looking at I'm I'm looking
at my pick selfishly yeah I'm just
listening just listening I'm gonna take
a healthy Joe burrow and the and the
Bengals uh minus one and a half at home
against the Buffalo Bills I don't think
these are the Buffalo Bill I don't think
these are your grandfather's Buffalo
Bills or maybe they are or maybe they
are I you don't I'm worried about the
bills I feel like they're a wild animal
and that's a they're wounded animal and
that's a short bus trip that's a short
bus trip uh I think that Joe Burrow's
been healthy for one game this year I
think this is going to be another
healthy game for him I think Jamar Chase
I just like them they didn't get rid of
T Higgins I think they're going to be
raring to go or roaring to go sorry uh
hey Paul the big cats are doing well the
Lions the Bengal tigers right hey the
Jaguars all right I got Joe burrow in
the Bengals minus one and a half against
the bills in
Cincinnati all right I don't know why
I'm GNA do this uh I'm goingon to take
the New York Giants oh getting a point
and a half I
uh you know one of their wide receivers
last week didn't say it but he did say
it and uh I don't know what's going on
out there I really don't know what's
going on out there it seems to me Paul
like they have all the pieces but
they're just not coming together I don't
know why I like the Giants
defense and uh I like the Raiders
defense too I think this is a great
number minus one and a half it's going
to be a close game and I think in a
close game I'm gonna put my uh money on
Daniel Jones provided he doesn't fall
down I think he's going to cross that
goal line and
uh I'm gonna get a win
I like I'm just shooting from the hip
this week I'm not going to lie that was
a pick I was going to take you you
that's great I thought you were staying
away I shouldn't have done that I'm
sorry me take the Pats I'll take the
Pats I don't give a [__] no I'm not
taking the Pats you're not taking the
Pats against the commanders and Chiefs
here's a little baggie of Coke in the
corner how much great is it that Joe
Biden's [__] son's doing blow in the
White House hey they call it the White
House for a reason I love that he went
like this and went up to a baby he goes
YY do do you think that do you think
that any of Donald Trump's straws were
left over from all the McDonald's he had
wouldn't that be hilarious if he no they
had the condiments he had the condiments
left in the draw he he had like the
sauces no yeah he's using a leftto like
Trump had a whole drawer full of straws
from all the McDonald's Coca-Cola drinks
and he's taking them and he's doing blow
I it's where this country's at Paul it's
[__] fantastic this country right now
is in the second half of Good Fellas
when we driving around looking up at the
helicopters should I do this I don't
know if I'm going to do this the
Dolphins Chiefs is an absolute scary
stay away from game and there's
something is it it's in Kansas City the
Chiefs are coming off a that was like
that was like Halloween like I feel like
someone else was dressed up as the
Chiefs oh that's right Jake The Snake
see Jake The Snake just jumped in and
said it's in Germany it's in Germany oh
so oh [__] that changes t on
F actually I like I like the dolphin
chances in Germany better I'm going to
take historically speaking on in Nazi
territory the Dolphins have done much
better I don't think Hitler would have
approved of Native Americans so I I
think they're gonna be getting the home
cooking out there I'm taking them I'm
taking taking the Dolphins I'm taking
the Dolphins plus one and a half taking
Nick croll's dolphins in Germany yes I'm
taking to beat the BTK Killers [__]
Chiefs I like that Paul you know what if
it was if if it was in Kansas City after
their last performance I'd be afraid I'd
be afraid of it in Germany I I like the
Dolphins I like to uh let's do that
Dolphins plus one and a half oh this is
Paulie doggy week Paulie doggy week well
I haven't taken any [__] dogs this
week so I feel like I got to take one uh
because I I like I
mean I'm kind of liking the Saints but
they lay in eight and a half pole I
don't like that eight I would have like
the 6.5 I would have like two points in
my [__] favor you know Paul hey Paul
why can't it ever go my way you know I'm
not hurting anybody think anybody gives
a [__] about me I was looked
over I was passed over
Mikey I'm not D like everybody
says not like everybody say I can pick a
game was it a half a point
um
all right Paul Sneaky Pete going into
Baltimore he's gonna get himself some c
cakes and he's gonna get himself a
little side you know what and uh with a
side of [__] Hooters wa waitress
action and I feel like he's gonna take I
I like Sneaky Pete getting five and a
half I like him getting five and a half
I like him you know uh you love Sneaky
Pete I love Sneaky Pete I love the
Ravens too these are my two
ex-girlfriends here you can't stay away
from these teams and when they play
together
it's a Love Fest uh all right
man oh man this
is what about this game
huh dude what about the [__] Monday
night special the [__] guy was wide
open for a goddamn touchdown Jimmy G
what's happening to Jimmy G man Jimmy G
poor Jimmy G manim G Jimmy G I mean you
know he's like a neighborhood kid he's
out there playing stickball right you
want him to come on right look he went
to go from RS to
riches Jimmy G looks like he's like
gonna be like a top-notch restaurant
coner just hey everybody he's just a
nice goodlook when he's older like when
he's old and gray yeah come inside it's
my restaurant ladies love Jimmy G who
doesn't like I mean he's a hard kid to
not
like well I
mean when you got the [__] Monday
night special poll and we haven't
[__] hit one I feel like in a goddamn
year and the guy this literally nobody
around
him Fred McMurray what the [__] the
guy's name the guy's running down the
goddamn
sideline oh Dante McGill cuty what is
his
[Laughter]
name Dante McGill taan
hurowitz um all right my last pick here
DeAndre something or other I don't know
dude this is rough
man my last pick you took the Texans you
took the Seahawks
and I took it in the ass on that Raven
game you
know oh Paul Paul that broke
me that
literally that broke me I could have
gone on Oprah and if she asked me three
questions about that game I would have
broken down crying and she would have
been like we got the
interview should I no the I was gonna
say Patriots but they're I just they're
just not all right I'm gonna do it you
ready we have a lot of injuries on
defense everybody's coming down on Bill
bich he has a great defense he does not
have an offensive line I have won the
last two
Thursdays okay like Bill said it going
in Thursday it's like a guy in the ring
just coming
out oh oh yeah we were saying when you
pick the Thursday game when you pick the
Thursday game that's like you know when
boxes come out and they fill each other
out in the first round you know that guy
when the thing the bell rings and the
guy comes running out of the corner like
meets the guy three quarters of the way
across the ring that's what bet the
Thursday game is it's Peter McNeely
versus Tyson yeah all right let's am I
gonna win this week or lose let's [__] I
want I want I need a decision
early that's perfect it's Haggler Hearns
Haggler Hearns they just all right I I
picked the last two Thursdays hopefully
I can make it three in a row I am going
to take the Pittsburgh Steelers tonight
minus three against a new quarterback TI
who they got Mitch trabitz Mike Tomlin
what who do they got is it Mitch trabitz
uh because what's his didn't what's his
face uh whatever the [__] the guy's name
is that's the quarterback for the uh
steers Kenny got Kenny picket will play
Kenny picket Kenny picket will play
that's a tough name for a quarterback
minus three he's got pick in his own
name I know I know Kenny
interception uh I intercep
how many times did the paper have a
field day with his uh name well I fig he
made it to the NFL so probably not that
many um that's like when the Patriots
had a kicker named Scott
sisen oh the guy missed one and it was
Miss siss that was
it my favorite one Ali [__] shank oh my
God Ali [__] shik oh my God field goal
kickers oh they get some rough ones I
just think Mike Tomlin dude Mike Tomlin
at home on a prime time under the lights
game he just the the the Steelers are
always in it and Joe Bart's gonna be in
town doing standup the hometown hero oh
if Joe Bart neck's in town then you know
if if Joe bartnik and his dad go to the
game forget it's over uh yeah I'm gonna
that moves the line that moves the line
if Vegas finds out Joe Barton exps to
and stand up while the Steelers are home
that moves the line here's the deal if
somebody put a gun to my [__] head
and said the Steelers are at home on a
Prime Time game versus the Titans and
the line is three who you taking done I
got the
Steelers I think that's going to be some
black and blue football there Paul oh
I'm here I'm hearing helmets [__]
crunches it's not it's not gonna come
off like a Thursday game they're gonna
have a simplistic game plan on a
four-day prep but I'm telling you
there's GNA be some hits
Paul and I'm not talking Phil Spectre uh
all right we got you know G to your head
in your mouth you know what time it is
Bill oh Jesus Christ
it's time for us to [__] pick one of
these I got to pick a different song all
right here we go we have the Los Angeles
Chargers minus three and a half at
MetLife Stadium vers the Jets the Jets
are four and three and the Chargers are
three and four but healthy
now I love the Chargers I love the
Chargers too I love the Chargers I love
the Chargers I love Justin Herbert to
throw
one okay I'm with you Paul Paul I'm
[__] lock step all right so we got
the Chargers down the aisle right now
Paul we got the Chargers and we got the
nice long blond lock blond lock [__]
big arm kid throwing one what else bill
I mean if you look at the Chargers and
jets at the quarterback position I mean
come on Paul that's like me standing
next to Brad Pit
[Laughter]
okay uh that's a oh my God look at that
and what is that dud you know how hard
it is for me as a 58 kid to stand next
to a guy that's 66 with long locks it
almost looks like he's like visiting me
at the
[Laughter]
hospital oh we didn't do the hair Hall
of Fame yet this week got oh can we can
I use a young kid or no no you got no
hair Hall of Fame dude you we got to
have some criteria you got to be over 50
okay over 50 and it's as thick as when
you were in [__] Elementary
School oh [__] who do we got
um great head of hair over
50 over is anybody in the public eye and
you're just looking at them like my like
they can still like if they wanted to
they could get like the latest
haircut you know what I mean like
whatever haircuts in style you could
still do
it like Jimmy
Johnson H Jimmy Johnson could do a
mohawk he could do one of those Conor
McGregor Fades yeah I got to look this
up real quick great head of hair is I
would say hoe long did we put hoe long
in was he part of it might be thinning
though great
hair uh he's like one of those guys if
his hair is thinning then he's like a
baseball player that retired with
2,990
hits they're showing got to be nice to
the sports writers to get in we know how
athletic they are I got three minutes
Paul and then I gotta I gotta go we'll
be done in three I got it clocked we
didn't finish the Monday night special
though we got the Chargers minus three
and a half we got Justin Herbert to
throw one and we got Chuck Muny to rush
we got uh we got do blow with [__]
Joe Biden's kid Justin Herbert to throw
one Chargers to win by four and um
what do you think
Austin and a
safety Austin Eckler to score or or jets
to Chargers to get a turnover could we
do that all right let's do this Justin
Herbert to throw one Chargers to win and
uh Austin over under over under oh you
love the over on 40 you no no not I'm
just I just I'm just putting it out
there Paul that's like an appetizer
would you care for some or would you
like like to go right to your entree JS
don't score a lot though and the
Chargers do and 40 is a perfect
number I you just that just came right
out of your mouth like you [__]
already saw the game so I'll go with
that yeah so let's do Austin Eckler
anytime
touchdown okay unless you don't want to
what do you want to do Bree tall
touchdown Jets what what do you want
he's the Jets running back he's
good dude [__] the Jets okay okay I just
I you
know God bless those people and the
situation they're in but there's nothing
we can do about it Austin Eckler Austin
Eckler is going to score Austin Eckler
anytime touchdown Herbert to throw on
charges to win let's do it this is yeah
and this is the middle of the Season
Paul where teams are going to be who the
[__] they are all right and the Jets
they're going over the side there you go
that's the picks Chargers to win Herbert
to throw one Austin Eckler any time
touchdown guys this has been a preview
for week number nine go to the bmgm app
downloaded put in $200 put in by the way
Paul ver three and one again right or
you two and two no I was two and two
what are you gonna say so you went you
but but what' you do for October come on
dude 15 and five I mean that's a that's
a Gody record it's a Gody record death
taxes and Paul bery against the B oh the
chain is out the chain is out and here
comes Paul bery you put the sunglasses
on my chain comes out guys $10 worthy of
sunglasses anymore I'm GNA stare at you
with my half albino face tell you that I
can't pick a [__] winner to save my
life dude Billy win some lose some $10
guys and you get a minimum of 10 you get
up last week use bonus code a bur 200 do
the uh survival uh pool and we will be
back next week guys bet responsibly have
fun